what will the media do
without donald trump i don't know
probably collapse into itself
tons of layoffs desperate sell-offs and
no one's going to want to buy it
maybe you guys heard the story from a
little while ago cnn apparently
i believe at t owns it now i don't know
who owns it no who cares
because it's it's worthless now that uh
everyone is predicting trump is going to
be leaving office
i would say if there's one thing the
people of cnn and msnbc should be doing
right now it's praying that somehow
despite all of their efforts trump still
wins
because they about to lose their job and
i'll tell you what was really surprising
is that
there's a story that came out from the
new york times saying that you know cnn
cnn and msnbc are really worried about
what's going to happen
and in it they mentioned the president
of cnn jeff zucker is weighing his
options and may actually leave
now they say it's because he's fighting
with his boss but let's be real
18t wants to sell cnn they're in massive
debt the network is
nothing but anti-trump garbage and
if trump ends up uh leaving on january
20th
that's it they're all done even the wall
street journal wrote about this saying
what do we do
once trump is gone and they're not
talking about themselves because wall
street journal is fairly conservative
no they're talking about i guess all of
this resistance media the venture
capital funded news outs are going to
turn out to be a washout for all these
companies that dumped hundreds of
millions of dollars into them
and it's going to be kind of funny so
we're going to talk about that we got
this big old hack affecting the us
you know uh trump apparently they've
there's been some invocation of some
some executive authority creating this
like joint intelligence effort
and you know what you can't see anything
with these hacks so we don't even know
what's really going on
other than they're telling us russia is
breaking into our systems and
essentially it's an act of war and i'm
like oh yeah here we go
joe biden gets in office and then we're
back to the track we were on with
hillary clinton of going to war with
russia because they want to get that
natural gas back up into europe so we'll
talk about this we also got some
some some crazy culture stories we'll
talk about some huge influence or died
that's really sad
over uh i'm not trying to this is look i
just tell the story
with no disrespect she was trying to get
a butt lift and she had like 12 million
followers so we're going to talk about a
bunch of stuff
hanging out today is of course luke
caskey he lives in the parking lot yep
tim thank you so much for having me on
before we start i would like to start
off on a serious note
and um this is not easy but i would like
to publicly apologize to the viewing
audience
um it seems that i've misled you and
i was wrong and i hope you guys don't
judge me for it i hope
that you will acknowledge that at least
i'm striving to be as honest
and as open-minded as i am
but i had a couple medical professionals
contact me and they shared some data
some charts and some factoids and
i have to say here and i have to correct
my previous stance and i have to say
that the coronavirus vaccine is
in fact good it is safe and it will be
ending the lockdowns i know
my previous comments were skeptical but
after having these medical professionals
come to me
i have no doubt no doubt at all
and i would like to announce on the show
that i will be joining our
president-elect joe biden next week
right in my left arm
i will be taking the coronavirus vaccine
with him
because bill gates can't lie and
bill you want to come down here jab me
personally
one on one mano imano you realize a lot
here for you and and i volunteer
for your scientific you realize there's
people listening who have no
idea that you're joking well they missed
out and they're like
they're like oh wow that's really
interesting luke said that you're joking
luke right now for those that are
listening and can't see what he's doing
because luke doesn't realize it's a
podcast he's holding up tiny plastic
hands
that you clearly can't give him a
vaccine through
i'm surprised people are selling these
now with everything that's happening
tim do you forgive me for my for my from
for my indiscretion transgressions
do you forgive me what what did you
really even say though people should do
their research and decide for themselves
yeah that's nice but that's wrong that's
right that's wrong that's wrong think
right now don't
we have to change our stances there's a
video of a guy getting a vaccine
but the the syringe is empty and it's
going viral
and i tweeted wtf is this and some
democrat guy was like
you're so anti-vaxxed i'm like there's
literally no vaccine
there's nothing in there i'm complaining
they didn't give him the vaccine
why are you yelling at me and the
hospital released the statement
saying that they're giving him another
vaccine again
because there was clearly some kind of
mistake there and again a lot of people
are bringing up conspiracy theories but
i think this might highlight some
incompetency
and i think the nurse might have brought
in the same one that was just used on
someone else
he was it's the same guy someone come
and sit down get his shot
someone would come in i think he
accidentally took the used syringe yes
i think that and jabbed the guy with the
same one
oh dude could you imagine being the guy
needle stick
it's like a lot of people were like it
was a pr stunt and they thought there
was some kind of conspiracy or plan i'm
like dude the nurse just reused the same
meal
like he gave him the shot he probably
put the cap icon put it down this guy
walks in
he didn't realize he grabbed the same
one and it wasn't until nerves
yeah yeah on camera yeah and this is not
the first time this happened
there was an australian politician that
showed how she's taking the flu jab
and again it was the same thing
orchestrated no blue gloves
that's different did you see the video
yeah yeah what i'm saying is this guy
this nurse oh yeah it was totally
different but but we're showing
he was giving multiple people exactly
exactly could you imagine like
finding out later when people on the
internet were watching the video
that you'd probably be thinking like
wait a minute he gave me that shot but
it wasn't anything in it
where did that come from and then the
dude who did it's like oh man i used a
dirty needle on this guy
absolutely absolutely crazy and it's
saying tim i have to say i have to give
you a hand
here you're struggling okay thanks there
you go you should see the rest of the
body
oh my gosh hold on hold on i'm gonna we
need support we need to we need to pull
this back into the armory that we have
oh the armor
oh let's give him a hand so this guy
this guy luke is all like tim you got to
get this scope for your m1 it's going to
be great and then he doesn't know how to
put it on
well it's complicated and i don't want
to ruin the gun if i don't know anything
you don't want me messing with the
trigger
you have to take apart what you're
saying is your advice you have to take
down the whole trigger
and we both got this advice you for some
reason decided to get an
m1a rifle for i don't know maybe some
historical purposes no that is not a hit
that is not a
home
especially with modern rifles that are
out there that actually do
work well with scopes and if you have a
long-range rifle you wanna know the
truth what it's all they had
in jersey they were sold out of
everything what are you doing in jersey
movie i told you i told you you got
pennsylvania you went to jersey
no no no that was years ago yes yes
yes years ago did you know years ago you
didn't say go to pennsylvania three
years ago you were like why are you
leaving new york new york's the best
yeah uh i i did but i was traveling a
lot
and leaving that hell hole as much as i
could but but there was something to the
city that was pretty amazing especially
as you're younger and you get to meet a
lot of people
you were late to the party bro i got out
a long time ago see if you bought a
house in the middle of nowhere i'd be in
your parking lot
yeah but see i got the house and you're
like yo i got to get out of new york i
was like bro i got a parking lot i know
you've been telling me to come down for
a long time i've been in new hampshire
i was supposed to be in florida two
weeks ago or three weeks ago but i'm
somehow stuck
here we i mean and um i i you know we
still don't have anything official while
the blizzard happened that you know that
wasn't nice yeah tim came out and he was
like i'm gonna skateboard the blizzard
i'm like i just started cursing at him
because i'm on top of my rv
on my instagram and yeah and and and we
got snowboards
lids won't give me a broom because he
thinks i'm going to break it yeah he
brought my other one
i broke my own brew i would buy you
another broom we have one of those big
squeegees for a shuffle in the snow yes
it's it's not fun
if you want to see i'm supposed to be in
florida shoveling that snow it's on my
instagram page i got about seven seconds
of video and it's hot
okay hey did you tell adam to install
the scope
uh adam said he's too busy doesn't want
to do it i want to turn
build up his gunsmithing skill smithing
yeah
i mean i could do it it's just going to
take a long time and
it's difficult to take out the whole
it's difficult to take out the whole
trigger sequence inside and then put it
back together trigger mechanism yeah
that's not easy to to do and if you mess
up you bit off more than you could you
yes your eyes were bigger than the the
ball
a little bit keep your eyes eyes on the
process now you have a pretty cool
scope that you could put on an actual
working good rifle
it's a camera combination basically the
m1 is just like a hunting rifle
it's like historical it's like a world
war ii yeah that's the m1 garand
was m1a but it was all they had um
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna you know
name every single you know gun that i
got but that was one of them
yes there's much more to say about this
i don't know i i disagree we have our we
have our you know point of views but
i just said there's much more practical
ones you disagree with me that you just
told me
more than the m1 yes i know but i think
there's more decision making here
uh consideration uh but again we were
very limited
to a store yeah and they had squirt guns
in this one yeah squirt guns
because they were sold out yes yes it's
it's crazy what's going out there
especially with so many new gun owners
this year in the united states
we're talking about tens of millions of
people finally for the first time in
their life
picking up and buying a rifle and that's
a testament of the time but also shows
you how
you got it's hard to get to you got to
think about the the tactics of the left
and the right
and i keep saying the left screen that
healthcare is a human right and i'm like
bro that's someone's labor you know what
i mean yeah
but i i gotta i gotta i come up with a
solution it's not even my solution other
people have said it
how about we get universal healthcare we
all agree to it
and then we also get universal gun
ownership meaning you can walk in
the government like you get one
government gun and the government gives
you a gun
i'm not this is called the gun i'm not
being serious do you have the gun
no what do you mean the gun they get you
got to get the gun when you turn this
18. you go to the you go to the the
department of gun services
i think we should be reprinting our guns
and then you go in and you're like yeah
i'm 18 it's my birthday and they're like
well you have to get a gun it's it's a
it's a human right
what if you had to get in there so think
about it no this is a really good
argument and
and it is hear me out when they say
health care is a human right
what they're implying is that access to
good affordable health care is the right
that if it exists you should
have access to it and i'm like okay well
self-defense is also a human right the
right to defend yourself from harm
so if you're saying we need universal
health care to provide a labor and
technology to individuals so they can
have access to that
then so basically what you're saying is
this if the health care exists it should
be their right
okay fine that means if the technology
exists to help save your life
people should not be barred from getting
it so that means if self-defense
is a human right which it is we actually
have like exemptions for killing other
people if it's in self-defense
then you should be granted universal
access to the best tools for yourself
you should get a
voucher because not everyone one
document free paid for by the government
or like the value of one gun
if you spend it on a gun or something
like that the value or a lot of people
are gonna be like why do we why do you
need a firearm
and and to those people i'm like why do
you need a fire extinguisher
if you don't believe in having
preventative tools
why would you want to have a fire
extinguisher in your house
so that to me is another argument ask
someone where their fire extinguisher is
most people are gonna be like i've got
like 17 of them in this house we have a
ton
but if you ask a regular person they
might be a like um it's
it's i think it's under the stairs
where's your first aid kit
i think it's in the bathroom did you
check
lots of people especially in the city
are wildly unprepared
and uh i could only imagine i mean right
now we're still in a time
and period where everything is readily
available but after
traveling the world and being in some
conflict countries you
you learn that a lot of the things that
are
around us right now we're taking uh
advantage of
and a lot of people aren't as lucky as
we are especially
in the world and when we look at the
united states we are a first world
country
let's let's look extremely spoiled we
got we got well let's get into the first
segment because we got a good segue for
this uh don't forget you know ian's
chilling yeah
we didn't do that did you get paintball
uh airsoft paintball
pellets no no they're not paintball
they're just biodegradable
yeah yeah i want to get paintball
pellets that'd be fun so don't forget to
smash that like button
comment subscribe we're live at 8 pm
live and uh lydia's producing i'm over
here in the corner
but let's talk about this first story
because i think this uh there's a lot of
talk about
with the media and and the chaos and all
that stuff so we had this story come out
i covered this earlier on my main
channel youtube.comcast
cnn cnn and msnbc fret over post-trump
future but i think one of the most
significant portions of this article is
where they say
that cnn's president jeffrey a zucker is
weighing whether to exit the network
amid some tension with his new boss
jason killer killer is that really it
well it's like kylar but it says
killer jason kira the warner media chief
executive whose background is in tech
not journalism mr zucker is mulling his
options over the holidays no no hold on
you can't criticize that guy because his
background's intact when jeff zucker
is running a news organization i'm sorry
i'll do air quotes news organization
when his background is in reality tv
spare me your best what was his uh
reality show background the apprentice
oh wow
oh it's personal i didn't know that you
know that no what if this is all just
like
one big hoax like like
you know like the the government the
illuminati what the real conspiracy is
that it's just like
it's all scripted like everything
everything we're like i'm gonna make you
so
bad and you go crazy when i do it so
jeff zucker and trump are sitting in a
room and it's like for the next show
it's going to be trump as president
we're going to make so much money
trump's like it's a brilliant idea
you're the best jeff i love you and he
shakes his hand well if you remember
before donald trump the mainstream media
was on its way out
a lot of people weren't taking them
seriously their viewership was going
down
and then out comes this orange glorious
man
that gave him all the attention that
gave him the drama that gave him the wwe
kind of wrestling entertainment that
people were striving for and and there
is an
argument to make here that donald trump
did save the mainstream media because
well that's a fact
i'm not even kidding that is a hard fact
all of these companies were collapsing
there were layoffs
every other day like between between
2012 and 2016 were they just no
like 2014 to 2016. what were they doing
from 2011 to 14.
there was a mix of writing off of the
occupy
and uh and ron paul movements and then
they started to realize that
intersectionality and social justice was
making people really angry
and angry people share more so they
started going nuts ramping up videos of
cops beating people
writing songs about it and there was
there was one website mike.com
started as libertarian ron paul program
like
that was a big influence on mines what
time but then what they started doing
they started uh you know putting up
police brutality videos
and finding that it mixed with social
justice narratives better
and then the website just became a
social justice media company
then we started seeing there was
something called like ad
was it called like ad rights traffic
distribution or whatever
where these companies would be like we
get a million views
we'll sell the rights to those views to
you to run ads on our content
and then companies like vice would claim
they were getting you know 100 million
views because they were actually buying
the rights to other content
so it was this big kind of i wouldn't
call it fraud or a scam or anything like
that
but like when you go to someone who
claims scammish
imagine imagine imagine if i claimed
my youtube channel like so you go to
socialblade you can see how many views
my channels get my
you know it's like i think right now
i've reduced the amount of content i've
been producing a little bit so it's like
60 70 million or whatever maybe maybe a
little bit
i think it's around per month i think
it's like 75 million it was at 100 a few
months ago way bigger with the election
but i've pulled some of the con you know
i've done a little bit less content
imagine if i if i like went to a
thousand channels
that made videos of people drinking
bottled water nothing else
and i said sign the rights to your
viewership to me
and then i found another 25 million
views that were worthless
that make no money and then i started
telling everybody i get 100 million
my network has exactly that's what they
were doing so
at some point before trump everything
started falling apart they started
laying people off
you know shane smith the ceo of vice was
like there's going to be a bloodbath in
digital media
and we saw evaluations tanking then
along comes trump
and then all of a sudden these media
outlets realized if we say the orange
man is bad
people click that button wow and you
brought up a very important point
because there was even psychological
studies that pointed about how if you
make someone emotional if you make
someone angry if you make them feel a
very
strong negative emotion that leads to
more
sharing of articles sharing of links
sharing of news stories
and i remember watching a documentary
about this new kind of
online internet news business and seeing
people in the newsroom
with just uh you know graphics about how
many shares their articles get
and it would be that's out of the 10
most shared articles
per day yeah and it was right in front
of everyone and they were always trying
to beat each other
who would get the most clicks who would
have the most outrageous headlines who
would get the most
potential and when you have a system
like that we have to understand that's
going to have some significant
consequences for the general public
let me tell you guys a story when i was
down in ferguson when the riots were
breaking out
and there's cops you know lobbing you
know i was there gas and everything
i did one of the biggest streams ever
this is really funny to think about
because we get more viewers on this show
now than i would get like mobile
streaming on the street but
so when i was like i was showing one
night that i get on my entire youtube
channel in a year
when i was in a lifetime in ten years
when i was streaming in ferguson
and we uh so my live stream had like we
had it was it was it was being displayed
in three different pages
for a total of like 70 000 concurrent
viewers at the height of these riots
when all was said and done and the riots
lit up and the buildings were like a
whole city block west florist was
engulfed in flames
you drive down the street you could feel
the heat in your car from how big the
flames were
viewership was insane it was massive out
there were bullets flying i'm hitting
the ground
the cops are like run run run there's
tear gas everywhere
and you know what when everything
wrapped up and i got on the phone with
the people back in the vice
newsroom you know the one i would say
the first thing they told me was
bro you just broke the record for
concurrence the first time a sub channel
surpassed the parent channel bro and i'm
like
yes that was it they were like we can't
believe it
because vice news was not vice it was
just like a sub chat chatter
but we got more concurrence dude yeah
they weren't like
it's a sad day man i can't believe these
buildings are you all right
yeah yeah i was going to say are you
okay did you get shot
no but listen listen we're all vultures
yeah right we're all vultures
so so was i gonna was i gonna be like
how dare you say that to me you should
be
asking me if no i was like wow awesome i
can't believe how well we did
yeah and that is kind of a sociopathic
mentality
especially with everything that was that
was happening in ferguson
and there used to be this kind of slogan
in news
if it bleeds at least it used to be now
i think the slogan is let's butcher
some style cut everyone open up
in the nastiest the most disgusting way
and then we have ourselves the title
it used to be if it bleeds it leads now
it's if it bleeds orange
it leads ah orange man now but that
orange
sweet elixir is coming to an end and
when it comes to an
end there's going to be a big reckoning
we're going to see a lot of these media
companies delicious each other up
it's gonna be disgusting there's gonna
be a lot of fired starbucks drinking
flip-flop wearing yuppies
in the city that won't have a job
anymore and it's good there's gonna be a
huge
economic reckoning especially with i
think a digital marketing media collapse
which how can you say is not coming when
their evil villain
is leaving and they won't have anyone
else let's talk about the serious
ramifications of what the media has
become
i'll put it this way i'd like you to
imagine donald trump walking down the
street with a smile on his face waving
to people
and there's a bunch of rats chasing him
nibbling at his at his coattails and his
shoes
and he's constantly like kicking them
away that's what the media has become
the wall street journal writes what for
an op-ed in the wall street journal says
what will we do without trump
a reckoning for resistance media but
they make a very very important point
they're not just saying oh no without
trump what are we right about
they're pointing out that eric swalwell
was caught banging a chinese spy
and the new york times has not covered
it good point
you'd think a a someone who sits on the
intelligence oversight committee in
congress
who was sleeping with a chinese spy
would be front page
news but it's not you know why because
passively in a meeting one source
says donald trump entertained the idea
of not leaving the white house
though the idea was quickly shot down
and trump agreed it was a bad idea boom
headline
yep nothing so today i'm reading the
news and it's like trump refuses to
leave the white house
and i'm like wow i wonder what the
source is for this and it was a passive
little sentence in the bottom of a cnn
article
but someone saw it and they were like
trump even suggested what you know
asked his aides what if he didn't leave
the white house and the idea was quickly
shot down and trump agreed
but someone sees that they blow it up in
this big headline trump refusing to
leave the white house and i'm like
i saw the headline and i didn't even
want to read the article because i'm
like oh it has trump in it that means
there's most likely some disinformation
a bull crap on it with someone just
making something up
just to get their headlines just to get
their clicks and it's so disingenuous
but it also
is so hurtful for the political
discourse that is happening in this
country
that has been bastardized that has been
destroyed
that has been savaged by these brutes
who only want clicks fame attention and
ad revenue
that has essentially destroyed any kind
of
understanding of media and we're living
in this bizarre world
where there's going to be finally
finally a correction
and they're going to realize holy cow
they're in utter trouble look at the
article that the washington post ran
with today let me read you the headline
from the washington post
p buddha judge is right airports are
romantic
that's it that's their headline who's
going to read that that's right news
who's going to like want to read that
also it's important to note
that the washington post is known as the
kind of cia deep state newspaper
and of course buddha judge does have
ties to intelligence agencies
as well so i was once at an airport and
i saw an old guy
sneeze into his hand then look around
and then wipe his hand on the seat
romantic wrong man oh my gosh nothing
screams romance like
airport security airport security and
blue rubber gloves you know
what i'm talking about there yeah i i
yeah nothing
that's that that that's romance you know
what we should we should we should do a
a a short you know a short film about
the love story of a tsa agent
who has to you know you know get a good
feel on somebody
and then they fall in love and he looks
up and looks the guy in the eyes and
it's romance just boom like
as he's patting him right right yeah
right into the little
well i can see that happening um romance
in an airplane
now more importantly that headline pete
bridges is right airports are romantic
no what's it like yes
no i don't care if it's an opinion what
yeah yes but what
what's the news yes thank you they want
people to fly they're trying to sell
tickets for christmas write a book about
romantic airports or something
you gotta click to find out the the
transport the transport
secretary transportation secretary
doesn't matter
yeah yeah so yeah he was like
i love the npr wrote an article and it
was like
he loves trains he's riding the amtrak
he you know they decided to make him the
transfer
are you kidding me dude yeah what are
they going to do now i i look about pete
buddha judge being the transportation
secretary whatever i don't care he's
going to read some books he's going to
say sure fine whatever i don't i don't
care about that you know ben carson was
made what the hell
head of urban housing is whatever i
don't care i don't care you know what i
do care about disappointment
judge saying he was the first gay guy to
something something
everyone else is saying about him but oh
i thought another thing to really
consider
here as the mainstream media numbers are
going to go down which they are
of course going to go down we're going
to see another concerted effort
to destroy people who take away views
from them
and use that independent content
creators who are not a part of this
don't worry don't worry donald trump is
doing everything in his power
to help them uh what huh by calling for
the repealing of section 230
which right again which would destroy
independent media and google
like it would tear google down uh no
google will be fine or it could run them
out of money yes i'll tell you what
happens
my phone wouldn't i wouldn't have the
word and my phone lit up i wouldn't be
surprised
if donald trump gets what he wants with
repealing section 230
and then all of a sudden youtube twitter
instagram facebook go
due to the repealing of this law only
verified users will be allowed to post
period yep and that's it internet
becomes cable tv
i mean already if you are a verified
user your post goes
in the algorithm and is promoted if
you're not verified it's not promoted
and very few people will see that
so again they're creating this kind of
inner circle of
this speech is okay the speech is not so
i wouldn't be
i i wouldn't be surprised if it happens
like you're saying it will happen
where only in the future you could only
have a voice if you're part of the inner
blue
check verified circle which uh which i
think is happening i think it already is
happening and i think it's going to
happen on a bigger level they just got
to go about it slowly
if they do it all overnight it'll create
an out they'll create uproar and outrage
if they if they ban if so so pornhub
deleted 80
of their content only verified accounts
are now allowed to post
if youtube did that right now there
would be a massive revolt
it would destabilize a lot of the
website and users would flee to
competitiveness it would make news too
they're accepting cryptocurrencies which
could mean
because why no pornhub pornhub accepting
cryptocurrencies as payments which
is probably why crypto is doing so well
right now
but there's also legislation being
proposed right now that would limit
people's
uh sovereignty and freedom to be their
own bank account
as barack obama classified bitcoin but
most importantly we have to understand
this crackdown on independent speech
it's just
as much as it is about quote fact
checking as
it is about destroying people's
competition
so independent creators have shown to be
a viable threat against the mainstream
media they have shown
to outbeat them when it comes to fact
checking when it comes to
telling stories accurately and telling
stories from a more
honest legitimate place and because of
that there has been this entire agenda
to squash
their voices squash their the people who
follow them
and it already affected me even today as
i was
fact checked officially by usa today
that said that my fake picture of
president xi and joe biden and kamala
harris as time person of the year was
quote
incorrect yes yeah my meme they're
fact-checking memes
which were clearly satirical bro they
factored the babylon b
yes but let me tell you let me tell you
what's happening let me tell you a story
i did i did a video segment about the
gop
electoral candidates okay i'm getting it
right this time
so what happened was all these tweets
emerged saying republican electors have
cast their votes for donald trump
colloquially semantically it's a fine
thing to say
okay so i made a video i said gop
electors cast dueling you know votes for
uh
for trump i get flagged on facebook
it says false information and then it
links
to an article that doesn't actually in
any way refute anything i said
so i was confused why was it that there
was an article what it really said was
the republican electors are unofficial
and they weren't chosen to go to a
college therefore
these votes don't matter and i was like
that's exactly what i said in my video
i went into depth about you know human
beings confidence
perhaps you know like 1960 in hawaii
when i see something changed
so why did i get a false rating turns
out i emailed the dude
and i i emailed the company that gave me
the rating and i laid out exactly what i
said i said first of all the first thing
when you click the video
it says the contested states have voted
for joe biden
and i'm like so why are you giving me a
bad rating and then i said in the video
i said these are not official
you know they're unofficial procedural
votes for this reason which is exactly
100 correct
and the guy was like yeah upon reviewing
the video and seeing the context i agree
you're right and i'll be removing this
this this this you know remove this
removing this uh this flag so there's
two things here for one
the person who flagged it whatever at
this company didn't even watch the video
just saw and went fake news without even
without even with knowing nothing about
it
when in fact everything in my video was
correct and they even agreed so
why do i have to email some small
garbage company
who it's some random guy who doesn't
know what he's talking about who has
written
this organization i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna you know
drag them right now we'll see how things
play out
but they've written fake news before
they've written overt fake news
but facebook has given them the ability
to smear
and defame individuals we rely on usa
today
fact-checking me today about an altered
image on my instagram i mean come on i
mean this is ridiculous it's crazy they
don't have the best record
themselves but most importantly what you
just said also kind of happened
to me in a very similar way right after
the election of u.s president
donald trump when there was these rumors
of russian collusion
there was allegedly all these
intelligence agencies that
donald trump colluded with the russians
i of course was asking for the evidence
and
was calling it out and i said there's no
evidence
showing russian collusion wikipedia
literally said that i was fake news
never to mention me on their website
again and if
even they had an editorial note in
wikipedia saying even if he does commit
a news story that is
uh something that we need to reference
or talk about like epstein island
never mention him mention another news
organization
that talks about him and literally the
washington post put me in the database
saying that we are change was a quote
russian
asset organization that was literally
working for the kremlin
pushing out disinformation because i
didn't believe the russian
collusion line i think they went after
donald trump they went after you because
your polish heritage
uh i don't think my my polish heritage
had anything to do with it
it had to do with me asking legitimate
questions
asking for the data and the evidence of
this russian collusion
which i said was not there that i
haven't seen any direct
influence that i haven't seen any direct
evidence and i made
those observations public in my videos
they responded with
you're a russian asset here you are on
this big database
promoted by the washington post
wikipedia says your fake news
no one will ever mention you on
wikipedia and this is one of the reasons
why
i still don't have a wikipedia and
there's no wikipedia entries
for me because it's totally banned from
even being discussed
so i've been totally just you know
what is it called disappeared person
unpersoned on wikipedia
because i didn't believe russian
conclusion which came out to be
absolutely interesting listen yeah you
know when i when i
when i see these stories about
establishment policies
and joe biden the electoral college and
they try to assert that
these things are legitimate and official
i i don't i don't see it anymore i
really don't because when i look at
what's going on with these policies
and when i look at what's going on with
the lockdowns all it's doing is
destroying everything it's not creating
it's not protecting
it's not it's not ensuring the rights of
citizens it's just
destroying everything so i see this
electoral college vote
and what do they do in michigan they did
the uh what did they do
they they shut the capitol building down
they wouldn't let the republicans in
and they were singing the black national
anthem all right fine if michigan wants
to do whatever they want to do
but you know i just find it really
interesting that we're seeing
dramatic drip like the cultural
differences between where we were
five years ago ten years ago is it's
it's it's night and day
in different parts of this country
everything's different it's like there's
no cohesive culture anymore
i look at what joe biden has done what
he likely will start doing now
i look at the mainstream media and the
insane stories they write like 80
of people believe joe biden is the
president it's like what what what is
what is this poll
now they're doing sixty percent of
people approve of joe biden's job as the
president-elect
what a job is that what do you think
real article that's a real
that was a real poll they put out and
now i see this check this out
because we're talking about crypto and
all this stuff you know what 35
of all u.s dollars that have ever been
printed were printed in the last
10 months i shared that one check it out
you got to show the graphic if you can
do it from the same from
org look at this so i saw this post
some lefties were posting about it on
facebook and they're
and they're showing this graph from uh f
it's it's fred
and it's economic research federal
reserve bank of st louis
and we can see 35 percent of all us
dollars dude this is
a huge warning sign uh
to diversify out of the us dollar
right now so here's what the lefties
were talking about
someone posted this on facebook saying
y'all are talking about universal health
care this and this here's what i'm
worried about
and someone responded with we can
deficit spend forever
and why would you be worried about that
because a lot of lefties like i think
aoc
even mentioned this well just deficits
spend into massive debt forever
and then someone mentioned the guy who
posted it was like i'm worried about
weimar germany
and then linked to a photo of people
shoveling german marks into a gutter
so i started reading about it i don't
think it's the exact same thing
but because there was a desperate need
to pay back
the the it was reparations from world
war one they just kept printing money
to try and keep spending it and paying
back you know to keep the machine going
essentially
it's not identical but right now all
this money is being printed because
nothing's being produced
now that's a serious problem nothing is
being produced
so they give people money to buy what's
remaining
that means the things i remember earlier
in the year
when everyone's like oh man you know
what happens now with with the lockdowns
and everything
and what did i do i went to the store
every so often
and i bought a normal supply of
groceries we didn't go crazy we didn't
run to the store and and buy like 10
shopping carts of beans
we did buy you know like like 20 cans of
beans and i was like we'll get some
beans and put them in the pantry right
and then i ordered these emergency food
things why the things you see on the
shelf right now
were made a while ago and so when you
start seeing
no one working when the restaurants are
now shut down in new york if that means
a lot of things are going to happen for
one
we're not insulated we are we are to a
certain degree on shows like this
people who make digital content are
going to lose tons of money
when they shut down indoor dining
because small businesses and restaurants
will stop spending money on ads
to get customers more importantly when
people aren't going to work they aren't
making things
so what's going to happen eventually is
going to have uh you're gonna have a
ridiculous amount of money from from the
u.s from the u.s government being
printed like crazy
and nothing to buy with it so what
happens you're gonna have big ol stacks
of dollars and you're gonna be like oh i
can't buy anything with it what do i
need it for and if you wait too long the
prices of stuff is going to skyrocket
it's already up 20 minutes check this
out i'm talking about hold on check this
out i rock it
i i put in my amazon shopping cart a
galaxy tablet
i was like i could i could use a tablet
so you know around the house i could be
looking in news and doing stuff
and then i forgot about it i got an
alert when i went to amazon the other
day and it said price change from 500 to
650.
yeah yeah for the same thing most goods
are going up dramatically
especially raw goods especially things
that are used to produce
other goods they're becoming very
limited in supply and it's absolutely
terrifying the bigger economic
ramifications that are coming our way
not only because of the lockdown
but because of the federal reserve you
said if they start printing money like
crazy
they already are most of that money 35
yeah think about how so when i was on
the show a couple weeks ago the first
time i told you
what was it twenty-five percent i forgot
the exact 203.6 yeah 23.6 that number
has already risen it's going to continue
to rise and most of that money is
literally going towards companies like
blackrock one of the biggest asset
owning companies in the entire world
that is literally in the chinese stock
market so we are literally
giving socialism to the super rich right
now
and they're transferring that money to
the chinese stock market
yes take a look at this from the street
and this is from october 15th 23.6
of all u.s dollars were created in the
last year in the last 23.6
where are we at now well according to a
bunch of posts that are going around
i don't know if that's the exact correct
number but they say 35.
let's just assume that's correct from
october two months later we went from
23.6 to 35
12 more points up they are cranking out
dollars they're spinning that money
machine like crazy
now some people have said that there's
going to be
rapid deflation because there's nothing
to buy
so but i honestly i don't know if that
makes a whole new said that
there's just been posts on the internet
saying no no we're facing what's the
logic
i guess the logic is if there's nothing
to use a dollar on
and people aren't working then they have
very few dollars left
and they hold them very tightly because
all the money's being transferred to the
to the amazons that walt you know
walmart the blackrock et cetera
regular working-class people don't have
any money to spend right so that means
when you say
i've got a gallon of you know a gallon
of water would you like to buy it they
go
i only got 10 bucks sorry i'm not
spending it i got to hold on to this
and then they go okay then how about for
five bucks no way dude okay fine two
bucks
yeah that's not going to happen no it's
not going to happen people value money
over human life unfortunately that's the
way
the united states is indebted we still
don't have the official tallies from the
federal reserve and they're printing but
as of right now
27.2 trillion dollars
that's an insurmountable amount that
can't be paid back
no matter what you do you could steal
the wealth of all the billionaires
and it won't even come close to running
the us government for one year
how much 27.4 trillion dollars it was
seven
it was 27.2 yesterday how much of that
is it was 27.2 yesterday tim like how
much of that is compounded
interest do you know this out what the
principal is and how much of it is
interest
check this out from usdclock.org they
say
the us federal debt to gdp in in 1980
was 34 percent
in 2000 was 55 and now it's 128.6
right sounds like an inflection has been
reached yeah we are
producing more debt than goods that's
what i'm saying
people aren't making things anymore and
they're cranking out money
to pay off debts they can't pay off
viamar germany dude
and then all of a sudden people don't
realize this it was in like the span of
one year
the the german mark went from like 20
marks to the dollar
to like was it like 200 billion
or two yeah i think 200 billion marks to
the dollar it was just people
shoveling money into dumpsters the way
compound interest works is it compounds
on itself
and it's like a j curve and then it just
goes straight up all of a sudden and
these people like alexandria
ocasio-cortez don't have any basic
understanding of any math or logic or
any common sense because
if you look at her kind of larger plan
of tax to billionaires
if you would right now confiscate all
the wealth of
all the billionaires in the united
states you would still
not have enough money to run the us
government for one year
so people need to realize the amount of
debt the amount of money that this
government is spending is
absolutely insane i remember going down
to venezuela i remember going down to
zimbabwe
if you're lucky you might be able to
still find some my reports
i remember also going to india when they
had a currency reset
and seeing the actual pain that the
government caused people
again just manipulating the financial
system in india they banned
particular rupee notes that
they just said didn't matter anymore so
so i landed in india and they literally
the next day had a currency reset the
government announced if you have these
very prominent bills
they don't matter anymore and they did
it because they wanted more people to
pay taxes because they knew a lot of
people were keeping their money either
in
uh shoeboxes in shoe boxes underneath
their bed
so after getting rid of all of these
bills the indian people literally just
had a few days to turn in all of their
money to the government to the banks
that of course would keep a record and
tax them accordingly on it this is why
and then those notes were
became useless afterwards that's why
they love bitcoin
i don't know if they love bitcoin but
the us treasury department
wants to restrict your access to bitcoin
and you being able to transact in a way
that doesn't involve kyc
the big banks and the banks of it but
they want control of it
and they love it because it's the ledger
is public and they can see
everything you've bought transferred to
every single person
forever well you can't hyperinflate
bitcoin that's the thing there's a set
amount that's true
and you can't manipulate it you can't
print it out of thin air
and if you look at the dollar the dollar
is as strong as it
is mainly because of the us military
industrial complex and its use of force
all around the world to make sure that
the world trades in the dollar
now when the dollar hyperinflates and
when the dollar hits the fan
this is not only going to affect the
united states this is going to affect
the entire world
and that's why i've been looking at
countries like chile that their currency
is not actually backed by the dollar
i've been looking at other kind of
alternatives as well but i think you
know we
we really need to start paying attention
to the alternatives out there because
i'm telling you i mean it it's it's
insurmountable bro
i bought bitcoin a month ago i've i've
been periodically buying bitcoin yeah
um not like crazy or anything like that
it's up uh
what 23 something thousand dollars and
i've
you know i i i'm i'm talking to you know
like you you
if you guys know max keiser he's the
orange peel pocket he's the one that
told me about bitcoin when it was still
i think a dollar or a few cents and i
told him to bug off dude's a profit
i had to fight the globalists talking
about the word
super rich and successful off of likes
trading and stocks and stuff
he's a he's a financial market guy he's
and you told him
yeah no when i was hanging out with max
and his buddy told me to buy square
stock i did and it's skyrocketed up to
like 200 no like 2 000. i
own so much bitcoin and i'm still sad
when i see that it's up 27 percent in
the last week
you know it's really just a sign that
the dollar is failing i sold
21 bitcoin in like 2012. and i was
excited
i was just and i remember i was like
what are you doing not then
another time no no not that time another
time you're not that's not true that's
not true
i sold once and i think i probably sold
it to you hell maybe i think i sold it
get rich because it might or might not
have something it skyrocketed up to 20
bucks
and it was this huge i think you did you
can actually donate bitcoin to tim on
teamcast.net
so it's you yeah i think i don't i it
was it was a couple hundred bucks i was
like dude
like somebody just gave me i don't care
it's 400 bucks man i could pay my rent i
was like you want them and you're like
okay
all right here you go buddy
so you think they're going to do a reset
loop that um they're going to be like
the reason that has already happened
that's another thing people need to
realize the reset is now it's happening
now
john kerry was a part of the biden
administration said
it's going to come faster than people
realize and it's definitely going to
come
under the biden administration and we
have to remember what's happening right
now
with the destruction of small and
independent businesses with people being
thrown into poverty there's a new report
that says that eight million people have
been thrown into poverty
since june the reset is here it's
happening and it's the largest transfer
of wealth in recorded human history that
looks like already have never been
richer than they are
right now and they're only going to
become more powerful
than than ever there's there's a a
threshold
that i i call it breaking the barrier
that you make a certain amount of money
in your life
you will never be poor again and so it's
actually we're not talking we're saying
the rich people
i'm not talking about just jeff bezos
who's worth what like 180 billion or
whatever
i'm talking about people of a couple mil
that right now
if you've got money to float on for the
next couple of years
you're not gonna be thrown into poverty
and unless you're sitting on pure cash
with no assets then i think you're in
trouble
because what they're going to do is
they're going to say u.s promises making
a good point here no look if dude if you
somehow talk about assets not money no
if you somehow came into a windfall of
cash randomly then sure fine but any
any regular person who's got a couple
million dollars
certainly has hearts we're talking about
assets not talking not just dollars it's
different the money is
right right right the reason that the
reason that's kind of a moot point is
you someone didn't just wake up and have
two million dollars in cash that doesn't
happen so a lot of people are storing
cash right now i think what's going to
happen no they're not governments
the government's going to be like
regular people's assets are tied up in
their homes as it's always been well
equities in their homes
with the great depression people that
had buried cash in their backyard ended
up
being okay after the depression uh
because they were still at their cash
they couldn't get them out of the banks
so it's going to happen now what i'm
making is the government is going to
recall the federal reserve promissory
notes
and they're going to start issuing new
dollars from the banks and all the
people are going to have to give their
promissory notes back and they'll have a
certain amount of time to do it and then
they'll get hacked
that's what i said happen yeah in which
country so which what is the
indian the currency research that they
may see
the point i was making is that there are
people who are
not that rich but are rich and they're
sitting back right now at their feet up
as everything burns down around them
because what happens is
they go to the restaurants and they say
you can't open your restaurant anymore
and they say but dude
i've got like a three-month buffer too
bad six months goes by
and now their business is gone but
you've got a ton of people who work for
certain jobs that don't
feel that either they're insulated like
it's a job that is essential and can
never go away
maybe a supermarket or something or it's
a walmart or something like that
and you have people who work certain
jobs day trading or some kind of
financial service
and they can just sit back and there are
certainly people who let's say they own
a bunch of chain restaurants maybe
there's a guy
who owns you know 50 i don't know little
caesars or wendy's's
well all of his employees are out of
work all of his managers are out of work
and they're all done
they can't pay their rent and they're
starving but this guy's got a net worth
of like 7 million
so he sits back and says we shut all the
buildings down we sold them off
i'm rich forever i got nothing to worry
about that's what the native american
chiefs did i mean just got caught off
look at bill gates bill gates 10 years
ago promised to donate all of his wealth
to charity
he had 53 billion dollars then
today after he said he was going to
donate all of his money he has 115
billion
you know why he said that though when
did he say that 2010 2010.
you had all these ultra rich people
being like we're gonna we're gonna do
the right thing and and donate our money
why
we just had a massive economic collapse
and people were starting to yell rabble
rabble rabble
and then we got and then he announces
things like this you know we saw
after the 2008 financial crisis when
people were really mad and that
sentiment was bubbling up which
ultimately became occupy wall street
when people were like the fat cats are
super rich and so what happens with
warren buffett
remember when warren buffett was like we
got to give our money away
it's not because they're like i know
deep down in my heart
it's because they're like if if if if it
hits the fan
they're coming to my house with
pitchforks so i remember when mark
zuckerberg announced he was giving his
money away
and they reported like mark zuckerberg
to donate all his money he was giving it
to an llc
to hold to bypass the death tax or the
estate tax
and many people don't realize most
charities are utter scams and they're a
way for rich people just to launder
their money
and that's exactly what happens in many
instances not all of them of course
there are some good legitimate
charities there's some good ones like
the one that the bidens ran where
all 99 95 of the money went to salaries
or the clinton global initiative that
was a great charity endeavor that
jeffrey epstein even donated to a large
sum of money
but also you know the best investment
according to bill gates
the best investment according to bill
gates is of course vaccines which he
says you get a 20 to one return
on he said that bill said that yeah hold
on hold on
i did watch this and he didn't say the
best investment is vaccines because of a
20
21 what he said was the best investment
has been in vaccine research because
i've saved many
lives he then later said i also got a 20
to 1 return on my investment yes that
that
should be noteworthy that should just
questions but i appreciate the full
context right because you need
the full contract the reason i tell that
context is because the fact checks all
say false
right and it's like false bill gates did
not say that that's like a mathematical
proof
if you don't show the entire proof when
i pull up the the uh the actual fact
checks
they're claiming what you said isn't
true using
a a false framing so when you know what
the actual truth is and say
yes he said the best investment was
helping people and save their lives and
i happen to have made a 21 return
that's the full context you can't fact
check that because that's the fact check
truth
yup another thing to really think about
with this kind of financial reckoning
that's happening right now a lot of
people are talking about the stock
markets great the stock market is strong
all of that is just artificially
inflated fake numbers and
just to kind of test it out i invested a
hundred dollars into the stock market in
september
and i also invested a hundred dollars
into bitcoin it's in september
so as far as my uh like stock market
investment which was just
kind of a general exchange we get it i
got
a hundred 100 i'm left with a hundred
and around twelve thirteen dollars
with bitcoin i already have two hundred
and four dollars yeah but but here's
what you gotta understand about the
point
bitcoin's value people don't get it
of course they don't let me let me tell
you something very very simple
right now when people are dead set on
fiat currencies
the value of bitcoin is just a currency
protocol
meaning if i want to send someone money
very quickly i buy the bitcoin send it
to luke luke sells the bitcoin
us dollars to us dollars transacted
immediately using bitcoin as a form of
protocol
so i don't care what the value of
bitcoin is i just care that my
the immediate hundred dollar value
transfers to somebody who asked for it
and transfers out
loot it's 100 cash i get 100 cash and
there's a small fee in between
but the people who are trading on and
buying more and more of it are
controlling that protocol which means
in the future as bitcoin becomes more
and more scarce people who want to use
it for its rapid transaction technology
are going to have to buy it from people
who are holding on to it
and saying only for you know ten
thousand dollars per coin they're like i
don't care
i'm i'm i'm buying it and then selling
it in 10 seconds
what do i care what you're selling it
for well that's why more and more people
are seeing it as a store of value
they're kind of seeing it as gold and
there's other cryptocurrencies that they
kind of use in order to have these
faster kind of transactions i don't want
to name any because i don't want to be
i was just thinking can i say the
craziest thing anyone's ever said about
bitcoin
yeah what is max keiser saying right now
about the price of bitcoin do you know
that it's going to go hyperbolic every
20 years here 28.
i think this year i think he's saying
this year you know you know what i think
i don't have a timeline prediction but i
would not be surprised to see bitcoin at
a million bucks per coin
i'm not i'm not kidding and i'm not
saying in a year or two or three
five times i'm just saying if the weimar
germany has any
you know any historical impact on or
what would you say any reference to
what's going on yeah
another thing you have to understand i
mean i mean buying power right now it's
relative to the dollar
i'm saying buying power i mean maybe
maybe the dollar goes dollar goes down
ten thousand percent bitcoin goes up ten
thousand percent
just like in the blink of another
because we're relating it to the the
value i'm saying consider the buying
power of the dollar right now
and i would think a bitcoin at some
point would be comparable to a million
bucks
and the reason is because bitcoin can
only it's it's it's entropy
it's a scarce entity it's not just that
it can only be destroyed
so if people need to use bitcoin for
transactions
and it's the it has the most confidence
many look these other coins they come in
they go
then over the next several years we're
going to see a decreasing amount of
bitcoins
but an increase in the utility and the
need for it
more and more people will adopt it and
more and more people uh uh
and and less and less coins will exist
that means the only thing bitcoin can do
is go up
but people don't realize it you hear
these financial people saying things
like
it makes no sense that the price of
bitcoin is so high it doesn't you know i
don't understand because they don't get
it
most people i shouldn't say most people
but a lot of people who are transacting
bitcoins
it's like i mentioned how can i get a
quick some quick cash to luke
i buy i go to a website i buy bitcoin
it's transferred to luke
it takes a few days for you to get it
though like if you go to coinbase and
buy it it takes if you go
through the kyc official establishment
kind of which is why you know yes
but this is the crazy thing about
bitcoin i could have a million dollars
two million dollars 10 million dollars
all in a passcode in my head and i could
go anywhere and open that wall at any
time
that's without anyone stopping me or
taking it away from me and that's excuse
me that's the way it should be
because the government can't regulate it
it can't tax it of course with bitcoin
they could see all the transactions they
can see where imagine if
they're they're they are taxing but
they're there are very vague and weird
rules about it that still have
it's just it's just an utter mess with
how the government's treating this
but more importantly bitcoin is the
first of its kind but there's other
coins out there
privacy coins whether monero that allow
people to have their coins uh privately
with them and privately transact with
them without a middle person being able
to see every little transaction like you
can with bitcoin and another important
aspect to really understand
here is that bitcoin is the first of its
kind it's not perfect right but it shows
you that there's a new technological
revolution like the printing press
that is here that is right now that's
going to revolutionize how we transact
with each other
and there's a huge element of it trying
to make it a statist
corporatist government nightmare that's
going to track trace and database you we
have to understand there's a big
element of that especially with
venezuela russia and other countries
even the federal reserve and these big
banks talking about creating their own
coins
when they know every little thing about
you and then there's another big battle
happening right now
with individuals with i think it's dash
monero zcash and other
institutions that are trying to make it
more of a privacy freedom
liberty oriented technology that will
liberate and free people but it could go
either way
and it could be a tool that could
enslave us or it could be a tool that
could
free us but right now that battle is
raging
i know i know a lot of people who are
just douche flutes that want to drive
lamborghinis and have little
e-girls surrounding them because they
made a bunch of money on the
but but and the market has been filled
with a lot of those
douche flutes but there's also another
element that that is very important that
came from the
this kind of ron paul liberty and the
fed movement
that is still there that is still
integral that is still
fighting for this basic human right of
privacy that i think is extremely
important and
stop looking at the numbers stop looking
at the gains stop trying to get rich
look at the possibility here of actually
having a technology that could be
incredible for humanity sure
sure yes but look at what's happening
around
us when we look at the printing of 35
of all u.s dollars in in 10 months
and you and and people are posting
listen i brought this up
because i saw leftists bernie sanders
progressive socialist types
mocking capitalism and they were like
look at this it's going to be like
weimar germany united else was like
weimar germany
antifa in the streets fighting with
people on the right
we see the proud boys going out burning
things fighting people antifa
four proud boys apparently get stabbed
put in critical condition you have to go
to the hospital
proud boy in uh i'm sorry not a proud
way patriot prayer in portland gets two
bolts to the chest
i think you're right listen it's it's
extremely
destabilizing printing this money like
crazy
telling people they can't work and what
are we seeing right now in new york
they're saying
we're going into full lockdown new
york's had full lockdown
indoor dining gone and how are they
doing
during the winter storm there were some
photos that came out that showed people
literally uh with a mask on full winter
gear on
just trying to eat in this huge snow
flurry could you imagine like these
insane government protocols could you
imagine like ordering spaghetti
and like it comes out and there's a
blizzard and then you're sitting there
eating
and then after like five minutes it's
just an ice block and you're like rising
again
as undercover new york city police
officers are walking around
trying to catch you to destroy you and
put you in jail
for having now i want to tell you i want
to talk i want to tell you secret police
now we've said some crazy things this
this printing of money is nuts
the federal debt to gdp is 128.6
how insane is that but there's one thing
that's going to break the camel's back
george clooney calls for movie theaters
to receive
federal bailout amid pandemic george
clooney calls for movie theaters to
receive
federal bailout money well he's an actor
so no but these are movie theaters
okay there's a difference between it's a
dead art form
movie theaters yeah no no hell wants to
pay a bunch of money to go sit in the
building to watch something you could
you could spin up on netflix now i got a
giant monitor in your house
i love movie theaters what does it look
like 50 60 foot screen
is nostalgia but it's it's a fun so
expensive to run
like yeah and they're in new jersey
they're being all shut down so
i uh this segway the point is i think
it's interesting to see
what what i think is really happening
with george clooney calling for federal
bailout money
you know you know where that money goes
from movie theaters it gets paid to the
movie industry
yeah he's talking about giving himself a
paycheck
without saying give me a paycheck these
these hoity-toity
say whatever celebrities love espousing
all of the democrat messages
and now the people they support have
destroyed the economy and in new jersey
where amc is like suing i guess and
completely destroyed
he's like oh you got to build the movie
theaters and give him them some money
yeah yeah yeah and then
and then you know when the movies can
come back let's talk about nazism for a
minute because that's the national
socialism and he's trying to use
socialism to
fund these businesses it sounds like
violence it sounds like pre-world war
ii germany all these people talking
about using more government money it's
been overused
yeah let's talk about national socialism
what do you want to use american money
for again guys
come on that's socialism hollywood
actors
are the people who have pushed us into
this mess not not entirely on their own
but they've been supporting lunatics
like newsome and and these and these
these people like cuomo
defending them doing psas as and at the
same time as they tell you to protest
black lives matter in cringy little
videos where they self-righteously tell
you
about how we need to apologize so let's
let's let's play it two ways
let's say they have all these massive
protests from black lives matter and
then we get a coveted pandemic okay
that's your fault you're the one telling
people to go outside
then the people they've supported
politically destroy all these businesses
and then he goes just print us some
money why don't you just just print us
some money
how about that yeah you know what man
these people are something else i guess
the nazis didn't have crypto i mean like
we we need to look at this like
pre-world war two germany because we're
in a situation where if a strong man
came in trump
if he had gone psycho probably could
have done a hitler thing
but he didn't well we're talking about
hollywood yes
so what do you think about george
clooney uh very kind of
i mean i i pulled up the article here
and it's absolutely just flabbergasted
to see so many low information idiots
out there always thinking that we could
just
print more money and then everything is
solved everything just
magically comes back about they're doing
it for themselves well exactly
about them what else is their entire
career about what else is their entire
virtual signaling about what else is
their entire kind of life about other
than
give me enough money and i'll read the
scripts and i'll do it and i'll perform
it in a better way than anyone else in
the face of the world
that's exactly what acting is but these
people are advertisements yeah that's
what they've always been
and so when it comes to the democrats
they've always
gone to these personalities and these
celebrities to use them to
to to you know essentially gain power to
manipulate and
it's marketing i want to make it seem
like it's all that nefarious they find
people that are popular
they pay him to say the message these
people get elected and now that these
people are saying oh no our industry has
gone belly up well that's what you
supported
exactly and if there's enough money
they'll do anything
for that money and it's kind of sad when
you look at hollywood it's truly an
industry that is extremely seedy
extremely disgusting
that you see so many horror stories come
out of and when you look at a lot of
these celebrities i mean we even saw you
know dr fauci i think he's kind of
considered a celebrity he came out today
and he said
you know people shouldn't really spend
christmas with their family members
together
gretchen whitmore the governor of
michigan released on a
in a horrible video with her and santa
and children
with santa telling the little kids
remember listen to the governor
and whitmer saying you know it's best if
you don't spend christmas with your
family members
but but hold on let me just make a
little point here because i think it's
important to understand here that these
same individuals are abusing this entire
situation for their own personal gain
and if and if let's say there was an
actual real threat say there actually
was a big
huge serious illness sickness going
around if they were taking it seriously
and
they were saying hey maybe we shouldn't
protest hey maybe we shouldn't
uh have you know best buy open for black
friday everyone lined up
outside maybe we shouldn't be
celebrating a presidential victory and
drinking booze and sharing it with
everyone
maybe if they were taking it seriously
themselves maybe i would
but i will never be lectured by these
fat cat plutocrats who don't listen to
their own orders
telling me what to do i'm sorry they
don't take it seriously i'm not going to
take it seriously either and it's
disgusting to see them
and this larger establishment always
push out these dumb ideas
that bring down our national iq to this
insane level where
right now we literally have santa claus
being used and abused
to make sure that little children are
low and worship a governor it's an
extraction
it's an extraction these people don't
think about the better future for
everybody
these people aren't the ones saying a
rising tide raises all or
raises all ships what they're saying is
there's only so much water in this bay i
better take it for myself
not realizing what are you gonna do what
are you gonna do so when we see people
like
clooney in hollywood he's like well one
of the what he's basically saying is
we're one of the biggest exporters so we
must be subsidized bro
printing money and giving it to you
won't produce product to send over the
world that's a bs
excuse you're an ultra wealthy
individual mad your industry's in
trouble
just like everybody else's but you think
they should bail you out
well maybe you shouldn't support the
people who shut down your industry and
that's what you did
and at the same time these democrat
governors who got the support from these
celebrities
are the ones who are basically saying
how much can i extract from the working
class before the system goes belly up
that's what we see with gretchen whitmer
she's burning it all down
and as it all crumbles she's looting the
she's looting the burning homes of
the town and then george clooney and all
these other celebrities are seeing this
as a massive opportunity saying give me
some
give me some of the the money before you
all goes bust exactly
yeah but come on remember the panama
papers how many of these celebrities
popped up in this having money overseas
yep a whole lot i can't remember i can't
remember who it was but there was some
woman
and i i can't remember exactly it was
some female celebrity and she was like i
had no idea
oh it's just my advisors were putting my
money in panama
and then wasn't it the person who leaked
like like one of the journalists
covering the panama papers turned up
dead
yes there was yeah that that
did happen i don't know the exact uh
parameters behind
that but the story hasn't been covered
as widely as it should
uh but just disappeared one day yep well
i think it was
more of a blatant kind of attack and
assassination
uh i would have to look into it more to
give you more exact
details but i remember hearing a lot
about that but i think the mexican
president pretty much
accurately depicts what's going on he
recently came out and he said
the lockdowns are just the form of
dictatorship
so he's not locking down mexico life in
mexico is a lot different than it is in
the united states and who would have
ever thought
that you know mexico is is doing a lot
better
than the united states how much you want
to bet the peso is going to start going
up
well peso is also very very closely tied
into the u.s dollar a lot of foreign
currencies are tied into the u.s dollar
so if we see the dollar go we're going
to see the whole world currency
wow be affected by it very severely as
the us dollar is the world reserve
see listen listen this is the benefit of
the military industrial complex in the
petrodollar
this is the benefit of the us saying
we'll blow you up if you don't agree to
our dollar
like you know qaddafi or saddam hussein
right exactly and
and again we have to understand here
with these extreme times
governments are just using this as an
opportunity the ship is sinking they're
trying to take as much as they can as it
goes down
and i think that's really exemplified
there was a recent report that
studied the lockdowns and the covid
responses from governments and
they ruled that freedom is the biggest
casualty of covet 19
not just were in the universe or they
found
well i think it also determined
determined ruled
found out included concluded whatever
word you want to use here but this was a
pretty stunning report
by an international group that looked
into all the government's responses from
africa to asia and they outlined how
you know in nigeria there was massive
crackdowns on protest
and you know the restrictions were set
in place to make sure that there wasn't
anyone challenging the political status
quo there in bolivia they postponed the
general elections
in sri lanka the government accelerated
its authoritarian agenda stepping up
efforts to control
independent reporting and quote
unfavorable speech
by ordering the arrest of anyone who
criticized the government
and we're seeing this not just done in
democratically heavy
states and cities in the united states
but we're seeing this done
all over the world using this pandemic
using covet 19 as an excuse
to ravage our civil liberties to ravage
our freedoms and to take whatever they
want for themselves
and it's working and they're getting
away it is working for an allen voting
thing was another example of that
changing twenty what rand paul said two
dozen states changed their election
rules without approval from the state
legislatures
yeah two dozen cuomo is banning symbols
he doesn't like
i'm concerned that this will be used as
a premise to war
i told my friend that we were talking
about uh trump's drone
strikes and i was like well what if my
fear is that the drones get hacked and
then
they're flown back over or iran did that
yeah or that there's like an
unknown assailant from orbit that
torches a bunch of u.s cities and we
don't know who did it
and he was like it's china if something
happens it's china and i realized
that that brainwashing hatred towards
china could be used as a false flag
that's
more likely it's russia yeah or
something like that that's what
this assumption that it's another
country it could be a privateer you know
a corporation i mean me and tim were
talking about this before the show
and tim brought up an important fact
that when trump
truly came in let's let's start with the
breaking news first
so this is what's being reported now
multiple uh outlets have carried the
story russian hackers
breach microsoft as part of their
campaign that infiltrated the u.s
nuclear weapons stockpile network the
los alamos lab and the energy department
officials reveal
so this is the latest update on what
they're saying is the biggest cyber
attack
in history i know that's not a lot to
say because cyber infrastructure is new
relatively in the past couple of decades
but this is an act of war
i mean that's basically what they're
getting at they broke into our nuclear
weapons stockpile
now here's the here's the important fact
in all of this how do we know it was
russia
exactly how do we know we even got
hacked exactly see
remember remember when they said the
gulf of tonkin incident was was
legitimate
then when people questioned it they said
you're a conspiracy theorist
and then they finally came out and
they're like we actually faked that
whole thing to enter the vietnam
do you know what it was exactly they
blew up uh a ship of theirs the united
states oh they didn't blow it up at all
what happened my understanding is that
the initial report was i think the viet
cong fired on the uh
uh a us destroyer i believe i can pull
it up but the general idea was that one
of our vessels was attacked
in the gulf of tonkin and this was used
the rallying cry like oh they've
attacked us we must enter the war
everybody who said it never happened was
called a conspiracy theorist and it was
absurd to believe the media was lying
about it
and then i think it was like what 10
years ago whatever they were like oh
that whole thing yeah we faked it we
wanted to go to war so we just made it
up
yeah but the the documents were released
and people found out that the government
absolutely lied to start a pointless war
that wasn't about anything that they
were telling the people it was actually
about
and because of that tens of thousands of
americans
died and then hundreds of thousands of
vietnamese people died that led
to tremendous human suffering and just
the united states again
losing a war that it was in for for what
reason
check this out check this out this is
what the wikipedia so wikipedia is
pretty you know like
pretty they hate me yeah check this out
here's what they wrote on sunday august
2nd 1964 the destroyer uss maddox while
performing signals intelligence patrol
as part of the desoto operations
was falsely claimed to have been
approached by three north vietnamese
navy torpedo boats
of the 135th torpedo squadron maddox
fired three warning shots
and it was claimed the north vietnamese
uh the north vietnamese boats attacked
with torpedoes and machine gun fire
madison expended over 283 inch 76
millimeter and five inch 130 millimeter
shells wow
in a sea battle according to the false
report
one u.s aircraft was damaged three north
vietnamese torpedo boats were damaged
and four north of
vietnamese sailors were killed with six
more wounded there were no u.s
casualties
maddox was quote unscathed except for a
single bullet hole from a vietnamese
machine gun round it was originally
claimed by the nsa
that a second gulf of tonkin incident
occurred etc etc so
initially the reports were all that you
know we got attacked oh isn't this
hilarious wait
the original american report blamed
north vietnam for both incidents
but the pentagon papers the memoirs of
robert mcnamara
and nsa publications from o5 proved the
u.s government
lied to justify a war against vietnam
does that name
sound familiar robert mcnamara and we
have to understand
this history of starting false flags in
order to get a country into war
is something that's common and it
happens a lot whether it's the reichstag
fire
whether it's even the conversation with
the u.s joint chiefs of staffs in the
60s talking about operation northwoods
jfk said get out of here with that stuff
well yeah but operation northwoods
literally talked about
having fake hijackings there's there was
of course the baby in incubators
in iraq 9 11 and there was many other
instances
that that happened all throughout world
history
that showed how very powerful people
conspired in order to lie to their
people to think that they were
things on this show so instead of just
moving on we stop
i want to make it pull it up we pull up
operation northwoods with a proposed
false flag operation against the cuban
government
that originated with the us department
of defense and the joint chiefs of staff
in the us in 1962 the proposals called
for the cia and
uh or other u.s government operations to
stage or actually commit
acts of terror against american military
and civilian targets and blaming them on
the cuban government
this is on wikipedia and you don't got
to trust whatever it's there it exists
yeah so again what i was trying to say
here there's a lot of instances
of this happening so to think that there
wouldn't be a digital
false flag as something that is very
naive especially when we look at the
revelations from edward snowden that
revealed
how intelligence agencies in the united
states have the capability to launch
false flag internet hacking attacks to
make it look
like another country is attacking us so
the united states intelligence agencies
have that capability
are they using it who actually hacked us
what actually happened here
good luck trying to find any evidence
well so he's trying to find any
information regarding to exactly what
happened
with this latest here's the important
thing i'll add i'll say to this
did russia hack the us and one of the
most sophisticated and consequential
cyber attacks in in history unknown
unknown yeah
possibly that's what their report is
they're saying it's going to be really
really hard to prove that when it comes
to something like the gulf of tonkin you
can show a ship with smoke coming out
you should look up the burning of the
right right when it comes to
digital hacks we only have official
reports and statements
you know the problem i have with it is i
seem to remember a guy named i think it
was clapper when he lied and claimed
there was no
rapper yeah no no he lied to congress
under oath yeah
general hayden and that said there was
no spying program at all when i
confronted him about the
you know uh family friendly show the the
guys in the nsa who were caught
uh having faster baiting yeah uh
you know super family i love that word
having fun with doing
inappropriate things with their hands
spying on people's privacy
pictures yes no not playing video games
sorry ian
uh i don't know what i didn't lie to me
and told me no there's no spying program
it doesn't exist of course they're lying
they're lying all the time
and edward snowden and julian assange
exposed a lot of that line
trump should pardon julian assange just
like just like ellsberg exposed the gulf
of tonkin in the pentagon papers
uh you know these guys like snowden and
assange exposed
this stuff with uh what what got exposed
by
any false flags get exposed by these
guys by what snowden yes no no snowden
exposed that they were lying to the
american people about
warrantless and mass surveillance
stealing your information
and uh and they lie and they and and
that's what and that's what they do
that's what they've done
and it's because they're not beholden to
anybody they're they're they're an
entity unto themselves the term false
flag is so basic
back in the day thousands of years ago a
king would go
or and take a flag of his enemy and put
it on a bunch of troops and then go burn
down one of his own cities and be like
they did it let's go to war and it would
be like okay
yep to get to get the people but but
morale is so when it comes to going way
back in history you see the point of the
false flag was
you could make people go to war but if
there's no morale and there's no energy
and
and zeal in that war people don't fight
very well
but if you show them look look they're
flying the flag of
gilder they kidnapped princess buttercup
indeed yes
then people will be like how dare you
they'll be really angry and they'll feel
it and they'll want to
fight they have yellow cake and they
have weapons of mass destruction
and you know the first gulf war was
really something
extremely eye-opening since they
literally hired a pr
form to talk about how babies and
incubators were ripped out by the iraqi
military
and thrown to the ground and brutally
assassinated by the iraqis
and of course all of that came out to be
an absolute
lie yeah and the media really didn't go
hard that that was a lie yes and then
people need to understand that was the
first
justification to get into the first gulf
war which was again
absolutely pointless the
and this is when hitler well this is
what hitler used as an impetus to create
the appeasement act
and he said that when the reichstag the
capital or wasn't it the enabling act
the enabling act thank you it's called
the enabling act um that when the
reichstag was burned down he blamed the
communists and said the communists
burned down our parliamentary capital
we need to take away everyone's civil
liberties and establish martial law and
that was 1933 that was the beginning
of hitler's reign of terror he also
launched a false flag attack on the
polish border at a radio station saying
that the poles were attacking
he dressed up some prisoners he blamed
the polish guy for burning the race tag
uh i don't know if the guy who burned
the rush tag was polish but there was a
separate false flag incident on the
polish german border
saying the polish invaded and then they
are attacking our radio stations and
it was literally just a bunch of uh you
know criminals that they got put in
polish uniforms and then shot
that was wrong yeah so they they did
some tests on the reichstag were like
could could what if hitler's set
happened happen could one guy
have burned down this entire building as
quickly as it did they've been blamed a
communist for burning it down yeah
of course crazy so we have to be more
attentive than ever
with the possibility of a false flag
happening right now
and if it does we have to understand the
people who question it or
ask for evidence or any kind of
information regarding it will be
automatically wiped off from the
internet so i think this is a major
concern of mine
because this ability to be able to
communicate rightful information
i mean especially during 9 11 a lot of
people had very serious questions about
what happened then
a lot of family members a lot of rescue
workers a lot of survivors that i
personally met and knew that were there
had very serious questions and a lot of
their voices a lot of their concerns
was able to go out there to the general
public because of the internet
now we're living in such a tightly
controlled space where
i i really doubt that they would even
have a voice
in today's modern day and age before 9
11 i worked at 9 11 i worked at the
trade center i worked at the american
express building across the street and i
would work with the firemen and they
would come in and i would ask like well
what where are the bodies and they say
well when we find a fireman we know
because
we don't find bodies but we find the the
jacket which is heat resistant we find
this white twizzlery substance inside of
it which is the bone
everything else is melted away and they
would fold it up and they would take it
and he said
we don't find bodies the bodies are in
under our in the liquid under our feet
running down into the east river
they're all melting and i didn't know
why i didn't know at the time i just
thought okay underneath
the glass building is hot the reichstag
fire
is not officially a false flag they
don't know officially yeah they've done
they
think they think that hitler was using
it as pretext
but the official history is that they
had a trial and they blamed this guy and
that was it
but they've done tests to see if the guy
could have burned down the entire
building as quickly as it happened and
they think it's impossible that it would
have taken multiple people
in multiple areas of the building to set
the fires and to have it all go up like
it did
yeah interesting so what happens if uh
you know antifa does something in
washington dc and then trump is like oh
and then he calls on the interaction act
like trump supporters want it could go
either way it could be antifa it could
be
proud boys whatever the excuse is we
have to understand that the political
establishment
doesn't care who's going to be under the
bus so
it most likely could be pride boys but
it also could be antifa because i could
see
a lot of antifa right now they're not
doing anything they're kind of dormant
especially with the lockdowns especially
with
the quasi-martial laws that are
happening which is especially perplexing
it should be perplexing for a lot of
people fascists would be coming
exactly they're not but i think there's
going to be a resurgence
protest and i think donald trump's words
of saying that antifa is going to have
biden for breakfast
i think he said something similar to
that uh they're excited
i i think they're they're they're going
to have a heyday under his
administration already
there is newsweek publishing one of the
craziest
fake news stories i've ever seen where
they claimed the proud boys were wearing
a shirt
that basically glorified the holocaust
and
that's just that's the lightest way i
can put it cause i can't tell you what
they're claiming the pod boys were right
but this is just
absolutely insane that's there's no way
that's true
and there was this image they posted of
a shirt
of an eagle holding the fashions the the
symbol of fascism and i'm like that's
that's insane is that on the back of the
us dollar
no that eagle with its talons holding
the arrows in one foot and then like
they're not holding the fascists
it's kind of like a bundle of sticks
there's a bunch of arrows well we have
to understand covering many protests and
demonstrations you know this too there's
always some crazy
insane person and if you want to cover a
protest if you want to make someone look
bad you always cover the crazy insane
person there
and you selectively choose but they
didn't have any photos of this guy
there's no photos there's no videos and
again it's very hard to believe anything
they say right now since they're
literally making stuff up out of thin
air just to generate
headlines just to generate clicks just
to generate revenue for themselves
as they're part of a dying fleeting
industry that's becoming absolute
we got to be careful about blaming any
political party for any of this violence
because that's what hitler did he blame
the conflict well that's why i'm saying
well that's not a political party
i know but antifa or uh pulling this i'm
saying with proud history of
false flags it could go either way it
could be blamed on antifa it could be
blamed on
proud boys it could be blamed on a
totally new group of people
that are meant to take the blame there's
there's a lot of possibilities here that
we have to understand are possible here
because the realm of of possibility is
very wide
and we have to understand at the end of
the day it's always their objective
that matters the most that we have to be
careful of dude
let me tell you it's only a matter of
time before we get nuked before this
channel is gone this channel is
de-ranked geez i thought you meant a
real nuke that was terrible
i was about to bring up the aliens it's
only a matter of time before
uh we're suspended because well i mean
think about the things we're talking
about right now
this good stuff these are these are
dangerous conversations the
establishment does not want
but google's not the establishment
that's what's cool
it's the most powerful corporation but
the establishment is
competing with them bro did you see the
video of the google employees
crying when they announced trump won and
the ceo and the president all the people
being like we know we know we're going
to resist and make sure it doesn't
happen again
they're the establishment they call me
and they tell me i can't talk about
certain things
they they they tell me this like we're
letting you know because we like you and
you want you to play ball
and i have my limits because i think
getting the message out to the best of
my abilities is better than just giving
up
but there's a line and we're getting
dangerously close to it dude we got we
got we got we got big news right here
we got we got to talk about it okay from
fox news twitter to expand covet 19
vaccines policy to combat
harmful misleading tweets twitter will
begin enforcing their updated policy on
misleading tweets surrounding covet 19
vaccines on december 21st so now
as we've we we're getting stories about
say
anaphylaxis out of alaska and i've got
democrats accusing me of being
an anti-vaxxer for pointing out a health
warning issued by the government
so even talking about what's true is
considered a
threat to these tribalists we know that
twitter is basically ideologically
tribalist left as well
so how long until i see a story that
says
bell's palsy you know people got bell's
palsy after getting the vaccine
they don't think it's significant
because the same amount of people who
get it get it normally or whatever and
whatever the point is what happens if
i'm like wow there's something people
should know
and then someone at twitter says and
that's anti-vaxx delete we will use the
fervor to start a new network
well we have to understand if they
really were to enforce
this rule they would have to take down
the british government's ability to
publish information
i'm saying on the merits of of what
actually should
happen there's a big difference between
what actually does happen because again
we have to understand
with the bigger point that i'm trying to
make here that this is a bigger disguise
in order to limit more speech in order
to control people
in order to have just an excuse to
destroy the competition of the
mainstream media
and to destroy the voice of anyone
questioning the establishment
narrative which they are desperately
trying to hold on to
because the only thing these people have
is their propaganda
and it only works if it goes
unchallenged and challenging it
questioning it is becoming more and more
outlawed
more and more dangerous to even speak
about and that's why earlier you saw the
way i
started the show there's a reason why
baby hands there's a reason i gave you a
hand
i'm gonna i'm gonna let you all in on an
open secret
the only reason this show exists is
because youtube allows it to you know
it's not it's not because you do it it's
not just about us getting banned
it's about the fact that 80 of views for
all of my channels come from
youtube's recommendations that's it
my views would probably be in the tens
of thousands based off of people who
actually want to seek out and watch my
content
but most people between it's between 68
depending on the content is
are not subscribed and when they see it
they'll go to youtube.com and youtube
will say watch this video
if youtube at any point decided this
conversation
is over it is because regular people are
only getting it because they're seeing
it in their recommendations
and this is absolutely wild because if
you look at our conversations we are
trying to be careful
we're trying to tell you both sides of
the story we're trying to
be as fair and as honest as we can and i
think
you know i don't want to you know i i i
don't think we could even compare
ourselves to the mainstream media which
is bloodthirsty for
power yeah i'm here this is mainstream
now
well dude we this this channel gets like
20 million views per month and cnn gets
210 million they're both mainstream
a lot of those are airport views though
no no no this is like a six-man
operation this is insane it's awesome
but also we have to understand uh the
tables are tilted towards youtube's
uh playing favoritism towards youtube
because
everything you search always comes so
let me let me just say
everybody listening right now if you
really do think we're doing a good job
and what we talk about is important
please consider
sharing the link whenever you can
because you know i bring up the
recommendation thing and i i see it
there have been periods where youtube
had these glitches glitches i'll do air
quotes
where people were like tim your video
isn't appearing on your channel
people just couldn't watch it at all so
i and it happens and it was funny
because i remember what the video
was but it was very much like i think it
had to do with the cia
and trump or something and it just
didn't appear just how strange was that
and i had no idea why yeah and so i had
to uh i deleted it and re-uploaded it
and then it was there an hour later hmm
very very strange could be but there's a
lot of strength
you know could be a bug but i think it's
like listen if i put up content
and randomly one day something weird
happens yeah you know maybe it's a bug
when it's the one video talking about
some
serious political still might be a bug i
know
personally it still might be a bug but
it's it's it's a question of
you know not to be too conspiratorial
we know for a fact youtube throttles
they tell us they do
they have de-ranking mechanisms it was
nerd city i believe it's a youtuber you
guys checkmate is really great
he he he found i guess these codes
embedded in youtube's
if you didn't if you search the source
like the inspect source on the page
you would find these codes that would
pop up and they were able to find out
that they were like d
rank mechanisms so we know it exists we
do
if youtube wants they can make it so
that people don't get notifications and
oftentimes they don't and then when
people don't get notifications they
eventually start to forget they stop
watching the game when we start doing
our own network that's like
shortwave radio slash mesh network
bypassing it's going to be so awesome
we've got the proprietary website coming
soon
very very soon it's being built right
now and that's going to be
where we do our best to make sure like
if you really are a big fan of the show
you come in and you can watch there and
you can get stuff there and even if we
get nuked we'll still exist but i'll
tell you this man
youtube is the town hall the city square
all that stuff
and people are going youtube.com they're
walking in and looking at this field
and what's happening is there's people
everywhere yelling and talking about a
bunch of stuff
and youtube is going check out these
ones these are big these are cool
and that helps us that helps this show
but at any point they could be like you
guys
get out dude yeah but then then we're
relegated to
you know our little wacky shack a couple
miles away and we're holding up besides
saying guys guys we're still over here
viewership will be dramatically
decreased video revenue would be i mean
look what you know
but jones gets a ton of views on that
video yeah yeah
one of the few exceptions but i've been
telling my audience
you know i i love you guys thank you so
much for sharing my videos because if
you didn't
no one else would be watching them and
we would be foolish to think that the
algorithm
isn't used in a way that benefits
a lot of the special interests youtube's
got us in a trap it's a trick let me
tell you the trick
when i look at some of these podcasts
so so let me tell you we are ranked on
itunes on this show
uh tim castaire is ranked i think like
right now i think it's like
one or like 211 or maybe 176 it changes
every single day
and then my main podcast is like was
that ranked 34
top itunes charts at one point now it's
down to like 130 something
based on the amount of traffic we're
getting to these shows we should be some
of the wealthiest podcasters
but we're not doing what all of these
other podcasts are doing
what's really interesting is there are
podcasts that have a tenth
of the viewership but everybody pays
five bucks a month so you get somebody
on twitch one of these high profile
lefties
and they have they have a hundred
thousand followers but half of them are
giving five bucks a month these people
are millions that's pretty badass
because that's like
10 cents per show or 20 15 cents per
show that's what that's
that's what i i was thinking like
youtube's got us in this trick where
they're like stay on this platform we do
the youtube rev for you
but don't you say the wrong thing and
i'm like okay we need both
we need we need a proprietary platform
that's what we're going to build
that way people can can can support
directly and then we can start to rival
some of these bigger networks and do
better productions and get bigger
and then we can't you know we can avoid
the bands and stuff like that well i
think
right now that's why youtube just
instituted a new policy
even if you're not in the partner
program or have been kicked out of the
partner program
they could still run ads on your channel
yep without sharing any other revenue
and i i mean my channel is fully out of
the program fully demonetized they were
supposed to review me in a month
it's been i think over eight months now
of course it's me
it's making me scramble and think of
other ways to make ends meet
but you know that's why you know the
t-shirts and did other things but
essentially down the line we have to
understand that this is something that's
affecting everyone because they
enticed everyone with this amazing
utility this amazing tool
they were like you know very smart drug
dealers that give you just a sample
of that crack for free when you're down
and out and then the crack head takes a
little bit of crack and then essentially
they become a full-blown
partner program they become addicted to
it and then they have no other way
no other avenue to express themselves or
do anything without that constant hint
of validation that youtube provides
i've got a very very important super
chat as we now go to super chats that
just came in
and it's very very important and
convenient and this is from eight
o'clock it's from an hour and a half ago
morgan h said i think tim is being
shadow banned i normally get a notice as
soon as the event is announced but
tonight i had to come look for it
that's what i'm saying so there's a lot
of people
who who watch simply because they got
recommended this and they're like oh
what's this and i'll come and click it
and there's a lot of people who are like
i like to watch the show every night but
if youtube decides it we just don't
exist on the platform anymore
viewership is gone and i'll tell you
this we're in a position right now it's
rather dangerous
that without that recommendation the
show doesn't generate enough revenue to
actually
exist that's why we got to do this
proprietary website where where you know
there are some podcasts that are like
ranked 7
000 in the world or 10 000 in the world
and i'll let you in on the secret
is your podcast that get like 10 000
downloads per episode
that sounds like very very low to a lot
of people especially people watch
youtube videos
my youtube videos get half a million so
to to look at a podcast on itunes
getting ten thousand
these people are millionaires no joke
they're millionaires
so i i tell you like the youtube is a
trick you know the real key is to make
sure you're actually running a business
totally and getting customers and fans
and and working with them and producing
content for them and you're going to pay
like extra to get the behind this or
like we're going to we're going to go
pros in the skate shop
we're building a skate shop so we're
building a skate shop we've got so many
rooms
we're gonna have events and we're gonna
we're gonna do uh one of the things
we're gonna do is we're gonna have bonus
uh member segments for the website
so that way you know like everything we
do now we do super chats but we've got a
couple more stories we never get into
right we got some some some creepy ones
we mentioned early on
we might not get to and that's something
we'll be like okay if we didn't get to
it then we're going to put it on the
site for
you know the people who want to be
members and we'll have merchandise and
discounts and all that stuff
because that's the way we got to do it
if we want to make this a big network
and survive beyond
what youtube is but more importantly
once we get this site up here's the best
part
we're going to have segments for members
only where we get spicy
where we can stay talking about youtube
will not let us say where luke can go
off the rails and scream about the
aliens
uh stopping myself from expressing it
i'll be swearing
but there's names just for no reason
just as much as i can
but think about that all of it the risk
we were put under for simply one of alex
jones on the show
yeah they they took a show that was so
sick and that was like one it was like
two million
go to [ __ ] shoot and find it you guys
because that show was happening millions
it was great
and we can up re-upload it on our new
platform once we get uh yep
you can probably translate all the
episodes onto the new platform
have everything there but we're going to
start doing the clips on youtube
the ultimate spicy segments you know and
then the silly segments too
and really just say whatever we want and
laugh and and and
it's it's crazy because you can't even
make jokes on youtube i'm like straining
my
mind as we sit here yep so this is what
youtube wants
and i told him this i was like you guys
are forcing us
all the creators to make something of
our own now i know a lot of people
point out other platforms they're like
why don't you go on patreon why don't
you go on on locals why don't you go on
mines
locals is a million times better than
patreon no doubt
but you still don't want to be under
someone else's conclusions and the isp
is a bit
concerning but they're not is hardcore
you really got to go and do
crazy stuff to get the isps involved but
we're ahead and we're we're heading in
that door maybe
that's why like mesh networking we need
something like the fetiverse we need
decentralized social media
that's what we really need and and and
people have tried to do it for a long
time but
we need a free and open internet like
the original
internet before it was squeegee cleaned
by the corporate
globalist the original internet was wild
west man i loved it
people were doing crazy nonsense you
know somewhere on the deep on the dark
web the deep web
there's a there's an animation of you
know macho man randy savage doing the
banana dance
on a geo city somewhere the dark web is
something crazy i've never gone to the
dark web and i don't
maybe the dark the dark apparently it's
in another internet that's that's
underneath the internet yeah but that
just means
stuff there no no no no no it just means
non-indexed wait
not the dark net that i think of the
dark knight yeah the dark net and the
deep web are the same thing okay and
it's a reference to
non-indexed that's where like the silk
road was
that was the onion network yeah tor
right that's that's different the onion
router
right so those were that that was
different or is a browser that you use
to access that stuff without being found
out yeah well maybe
trump will pardon uh ross uh well
there's uh there was a daily beast
article according to two of their
sources allegedly anonymous sources but
they say
that they're inside of the white house
that trump is considering pardoning ross
ulbricht and is favorable to that idea
and if that's
true i mean that would be huge i know
ross's mother ross's mother gave me the
first interview
ever publicly speaking about what
actually happened
to ross and her story's absolutely
incredible uh it's
her name the way that that everything
the government
said was happening with ross turned out
to be absolutely not
true the amount of lying the amount of
disinformation
surrounding this case will make your
head spin wow
and uh yeah check out lynn albrecht and
maybe if you put in we are change you'll
be able to see our interview
i interview her at least once a year she
gives us updates about this case
but she's been trying to get ross's name
out there to the general public for
a while because if you essentially look
at that case
the main legal argument against him is
that he ran a website
that other people did something bad on
which if that's the case
then mark zuckerberg should definitely
be in jail too right on well uh let's uh
let's go to super chats if you haven't
already
smash the like button and you know what
i mean it we should probably do
better promotion on the show of like you
know telling people to share the link
share it with your friends
there's going to be a very special guest
today but share the video on me
so i i retweeted everybody everybody
listening right now
um assuming that you actually like the
show maybe you hate our guts and you
hate watching
okay then ignore this but if you really
do like the show think about this way
we have right now concurrent viewership
is forty two thousand five hundred and
forty six
if every single person shared this
and that and that was what everyone did
every day we're talking we would be
bigger than
cnn we could start a political movement
in two days we could yep
but i think that's i think that's the
thing is a lot of people are uh
no disrespect it's more passive like
they'll see the link they'll click it
they'll turn it on they'll go about
playing their video games while
listening to a podcast or something
and so they might not be at their
computer that's why it's like you know
we get
40 you know 40 to 50 000 concurrents on
average about sometimes we get bigger
like with with alex we had 112 and
you know before that 160k so it was
really big shows but
they're not everybody likes shares or
comments or anything like that so
that's the kind of stuff you need to
actually grow and start some kind of
change in the media landscape
madison square garden seats twenty
thousand we've got more than double the
size of
everything square garden here right now
every day so think about that though
if if look if if you are a fan of the
show and you think what we're doing as
well and you know luke and what ian has
to say and
and lydia yeah and and who's awesome at
her job yeah some of the best camera
switching i've ever seen cnn
let's beat cnn let's beat fox news let's
beat msnbc
but they've got millions of dollars to
throw into commercials advertising
network buys
that's what we really need we need
people who's like if you're only going
to do one kind of activism it's
i want good legit media that's it so
it's not just about us and our pockets
about other podcasts other youtubers as
well yeah let's bring them along man
let's read let's read some more of these
super chats
sam meehan says it's official luke has
squatters rights
yep so i seen a lot of comments talking
about
luke is squatting i am slavic i am
i was born in poland so i am technically
polish squatting
me and tim still haven't figured out
what we're doing here this is kind of
just happening through happening
i literally what was it two weeks ago
and i'm like i'm only going to be here
for a week that was my plan i was
supposed to be in florida
again i'm demonetized and again i i'm
thinking about doing survival trainings
to her to to make sure i have more
income but
we still i mean you want to come on one
show friday you're like sure yeah no no
first i was like no i don't want to do
this and you're like
and you're like come on do it it's fun
i'm like and then like
i did it once and then the the other
time the couple gets
cancelled a couple guest cancels no i
know what happened what happened
people started commenting about how much
like luke is great he sure did awesome
i gotta say i'm trying to make sure the
comments don't go to my head
but the commenter i mean i even i'm i'm
even getting like two dollar
like uh cash apps and venmos from people
i don't know
i don't want to i don't know if people
want to be shouted out here but my
venomous cash app is luke we are changed
just for maybe
a happenstance but but the support
and especially getting the t-shirts out
has has helped me out tremendously but
also most importantly
we have to understand we're living
through one of the most important times
in american history it is more crucial
than ever
to share legitimate real information
with people because that is essential
right now and this is an opportunity to
reach people and as you can see i mean
i've been taking it seriously i'm doing
a lot of research i've been i've been
studying i've been making sure
everything i say is correct sometimes i
make some mistakes but
this is crucial what we're doing right
now and and it's and i think it's
working and a lot of people are happy
and it's kind of fun debating and
arguing with a lot of people here on the
show
we have an important super chat in that
you know for you luke um
demon king lamb says installing a
picatinny rail mount onto an m1a
is very easy so easy a fud like luke can
do it all right
apparently not he couldn't do it we're
gonna be figuring that out
after the show i was i was typically
doing research but it seems like a
complicated process i will get
there's a little thing with like step
one step two do you want to do it before
now i'm not the one who's claiming to be
you know the gun guy
you know luke i'm not claiming to be no
guy
well you know there's more problems
and they had like two guns but as you
could see tim is trying to fatten me up
first of all he's providing a lot of
stakes he's providing a lot of we had
flame
yeah yeah he's like he's literally
trying to fatten me up so i stay here
it might work it might not we don't know
what we're doing yet
but but i think so far i don't know you
guys are
giving me a lot of good feedback i i
think it's a crucial time i think it's i
think
you know i think it's working out pretty
good keep making comments about how you
love luke because i won't
want to keep him around you know along
with what you were saying about sharing
and how cool
and how independent i keep thinking
about like it's so easy to click that
button like the share button i'm like oh
an article i like
i'll just click the button but it has
such a resounding impact
so it's so easy to do but it's not like
equal reward it's a
greater reward than the amount of energy
the likes so
one of the things that make sure a
channel grows when you hit the like
button
it really does result in youtube being
like recommended you know
so i think we need to get like a little
graphic that pops up and says like smash
that like button or something
or like i gotta i got it there's there's
a fashion one there
i gotta read this just go i know go what
go ahead i know
it's gonna be something i already know
just go no you don't let's go
small sc says jesus tim an m1a is not a
home defense rifle
yes it is no it's it's like a turret
for what reason why would anyone have an
m1a other than to defend their home a
broom
what what what am i wrong a hunting
rifle
it's a it's a long distance old-school
kind of rifle
that like an antique all i know is i
went into the gun store and i said i
want to defend my home
and he said uh do you have a reason to
do you have a reason to be worried about
intruders that are 500 yards away and i
said my property is very large sir
and he says maybe you might have some
wild animals you need something i know
just what you need
yeah yeah yeah and uh dan or or orlowski
says tim you have to use special ammo
with your m1
standard 30.6 ammo has too much pressure
it can damage your rifle
so i was given 308 by the uh by by the
man at the store
and i was told online and by you 762 by
51 could work for it as well
yeah well there's special grains and i
haven't looked at this specifically
why have an m1a all i know is in the
division my guy had it and i went to the
store and they had no rifles i was like
i'll take that one
it was that in like a 22. we should
mount it over the fire both
very unpractical what you're doing if
you're if you're looking for target
practice and
if you're looking to get good with iron
sights yes
especially if you're doing medium to
long range you could definitely practice
with those but
essentially there's a lot more practical
firearms that you could use to protect
yourself this i completely understand
and they had very few weapons
i understand it's fine so i went in and
i was like i'm just busting your balls
you know what it was really was about
ammo too yeah it was about what kind of
ammo they had left
308 is somewhat available which is
surprising from what i've seen in
western virginia and new hampshire
uh 760 yeah 762 as well 556 had a very
big premium
but a lot of other ammo i mean even some
uh 556
is is hard to come by if it does if you
do you're very lucky this is really
funny i love this conversation
the buzz cjc says ironically while the
ar-15 is not a weapon of war
and is not fielded by any military the
m1a
is technically a weapon of war or
assault weapon yeah it was
what was it world war one and two or
yeah world war ii uh the m1 garand the a
is a civilian version of the m14 the
civilian version so it's not military
apparently
so what's it for like long range hunting
well like medium long range
hunting yeah they're heavy right they're
really heavy i wouldn't say really heavy
because i wouldn't know
they were i think they were better in
the mud than the m16 the m16 would jam
up
but they were so much lighter that they
didn't care in vietnam they so they
want a smith wesson 500. have you seen
those well
um yes of course actually no there's
there's a lot of firearms but there's
uh you know a lot of people that are not
available remember remember the joker
and the batman from the 90s movie where
he pulls the revolve around
barrels like 10 like four feet long
that's what i'm talking about
all right let's see let's see what's
this lazy murder hobo says look up the
atf letter on pistol braces atf is
trying to push the goal post by changing
definitions and band were the most
common firearm types what's that yeah
it's absolutely
insane that you could have something
that looks like a rifle but it's
classified as a pistol because of the
back end of it
and and it's just utterly ridiculous to
see the atf go after
particular companies the honey badger
was also one particular uh
gun and model that was also just
officially taken down by the atf and
they're
looking at making sure that these kind
of smaller
barrel rifles which they're classifying
as pistols that they're going to be
deemed illegal so overnight there's a
proposal by the atf that would literally
make
millions of americans felons overnight
automatically because of these
mid-range rifles which they're calling
pistols for some reasons the definitions
are absolutely backwards which just
shows you how idiotic government
is we got we got mike here mike here
with the super chat he knows what's up
he said
m1a is a home defense weapon if you
defend your home with it
these categories we apply to weapons are
rhetorical and stupid eg weapon of war
thank you mike that's exactly it to me
it's more what if
what practical what if what if way way
down
you know a couple hundred yards away i
see some like super rhinoceros
six foot five with for guy and he's got
like ripped sleeves and he's just
super soldier super soldier hulk in the
driveway and he's waving a sign saying
i'm literally taking shots though
and he's holding a sign that says i'm
going to kill all of you once i get up
what am i going to do i need something
to use your iron sights to
track them down and get one down
does it have a clip or is it just a
single shot it's a magazine okay
yeah wow clips they used to have clips
that's crazy you'd like clip the bullets
in and just like
that's funny they did have antiques so
they had muskets at the store it was
really cool
i'm surprised you didn't get that the
musketeer yeah so they might as well
they didn't have they didn't have powder
wadding and and balls so
a clip and a magazine are different i'm
this yeah i'm learning okay how are they
different a clip is literally a
clip that you clip the bullets to and
then put it in and a magazine
is spring loaded and you oh yeah i kept
saying clip before people kept yelling
at yelling at me in the super chat
they're like stop saying clip it's a
magazine and i'm like okay all right
we got a bunch of air showers too we got
a bunch of airsoft yeah the airsoft's
gonna be really fun to train with yeah
yeah i really wanna i wanna get
paintball if we can find a bio-organic
like paintball uh airsoft pellets that
will degrade into the dirt well a lot of
the airsoft
paints are replicas of actual existing
firearms that you could train with and
not get the exact training as with a
real firearm
but especially if you're a newbie i
strongly recommend you do that
rather than shooting your balls off so i
was thinking of us in the woods
hunting each other with like protective
goggles
it's called playing airsoft and we would
just shoot at each other
well we have armor so i bought standard
armor but if you get it like right here
full mask yeah dude i'm so in airsoft is
a sport
can we use flashlights to blind each
other you i don't i don't know i've
never that'll be fun you know
i was looking at this tactical uh drill
game um
they have all sorts of this weekend if
you guys want and we can do a 5v5
our team will kidnap luke and we'll put
them like with like a low
light like a light hanging from the
ceiling a lamp so we can only see like
our wastes and then we'll have like
a buzz saw that's coming down slowly
grab him by the back of the head and
slam his head at the table and be like
where is your team at dude i was like
i'll never tell
this russian laser tag tactical company
that makes all this cool laser tag
equipment like
like um flags and med kits and stuff
obviously
the yeah the laser some of that stuff
wouldn't work with airsoft but we could
have like certain things
like flags we should like capture the
flag yeah daniel maxwell says conspiracy
theory
spicy the galactic federation wants joe
biden to be president so they can bring
earth into the galactic federation since
their democratic socialist with an
authoritarian government
if you laugh you owe me an appearance on
the show joking i don't think i laughed
enough sorry
but luke and lydia did but there do you
think because the the earth
the earthens got inducted into the
galactic federation star trek they
didn't start it
so they it's already out there and then
they eventually what they they hit warp
drive right right and that's why there's
some kind of contract out there between
aliens and us according to some
government i don't think i ever told you
my story about when i sensed the wolf
man
across the universe i was meditating on
my roof and and just
let my electromagnetic field down and
and gazed out into the star system to
see what was out there and something
sensed to me it was this wolf creature
that had taken mushrooms and like
evolved as we had from
apes but it was a wolf creature that had
evolved and it sensed me and wanted to
eat me
bro he's on a podcast right now going i
never told you about that
i swear i was taking mushrooms and this
monkey guy like he evolved like we did
but he was a monk
he comes to me
[Laughter]
all right let's see we got uh cesar
chamarro says tim luke hypocrites rag on
cops being bootlickers for earning a
living
while being liquors themselves bad
youtube bad youtube is but bend the knee
for the sweet youtube dollars
well i will say that i we are heavily
criticizing and calling out you for all
of this right now and
talking about leaving the platform and
starting something proprietary not
leaving the platform but
taking a portion of the business off of
the platform because
of how bad it is the difference is i'm
actually
helping people know about what's going
on the best of my abilities
and the police that i'm criticizing are
not all cops it's the cops who are
destroying the lives of people
because the governor decided on a whim
to do something without any legal
authority big difference yeah
i i you know i kind of agree i think
there's a bit of a difference between
just
talking and looking at information and
ruining people's lives
you know the cops aren't just making a
living
they're violating the constitution and
they're enforcing edict
not laws no legislature or council
passed these rulings and the supreme
court ruled against them
and cops are still showing up saying i
don't care i don't care
i want that money more and they're using
violent horse and coercion
with the threat of violence to do it
by be with their paycheck partly yes
yep but at a certain point you have to
say no so us being on this platform is
actually
kind of the opposite imagine if one of
the cops in the department kept
stopping them from doing these things
and every time they went out that cop
would be like yo we're not letting you
not
you're not doing this guy you can run
your business yeah that's the difference
between us and say like
you know jimmy kimmel and also there's
accountability so if i was saying
something that was baldly face
you guys would correct me on it if tim
was saying something that was incorrect
i would challenge him on that stance so
having the free flow of conversation and
ideas is a lot different than using
force
you wanna know something crazy yeah the
reason why
the weimar republic had hyperinflation
is rooted in the strategies of france
and germany in world war one
france's strategy for paying the war was
income tax
they said we're going to get enough
money to pay for this by taxing the
citizens
germany said let's borrow money because
once we win
we can steal everything from the
countries and loot their countries
they thought they were going to win and
then take everything of value in other
countries and pay off their debts it was
basically like
give us the money to fund this war
because when we win you're going to get
paid back
but they lost and they couldn't pay it
back
and so they started just printing money
like crazy but i bring that up because
uh a blinken says for ian the income tax
was introduced
solely to pay the interest on the debt
to the federal reserve
why both were enacted in 1913 they were
done in tandem for a reason
i the income tax came in april and then
the federal reserve was formed in
december but of 13 but i imagine they
were
uh calculated around for the same reason
but there was also an income tax for the
civil war in 1861
abe lincoln instituted one to pay for
the war
so it's not it's not different yeah it
wasn't the first time that we came up
with it i don't think we really need it
do you guys think we need income tax
right now no
it depends um i don't know man i think
i i i think it's kind of a moot point
right now because of
like you know i was i was thinking about
this we were doing doing a couple shows
and i'm just like i don't care about the
anti-autonomous zones anymore
i used to i used to look at what's going
on in this country as our country
and then i realized when i saw the
autonomous sun i was like i don't care
and then i thought about why is it that
i don't care anymore oh because i don't
view portland as the same place as where
i am now
i don't think that we have anything in
common for the most part so they can do
their thing
why would i complain they voted for it
they want it just don't mess with
me i guess i'm kind of like i kind of
want to i've been teasing the idea of
defaulting on the federal reserve
interest not necessarily the entire debt
to the thing but
just the interest itself and maybe the
the the income taxes used to pay for the
interest so if we get rid income tax we
could just stop paying interest on our
loans
we got we got a super chat here it's a
big one from empreb he says i want
answer
two things tim will you ever have nick
fuentes on your show
yes or no and why did lisa block him i
don't know who lisa is
we saw and the answer is yes i will the
problem is
this is the only person where people are
non-stop emailing messaging
and i will tell you what i absolutely
won't do i will not invite someone on
the show because people keep messaging
me demanding that i do it will not bend
the knee
it's not about bending the knee it's
about i'm i'm like i really don't want
people making a habit of just
flooding our comments with names oh
peter schiff
that's another one people recommend him
yeah he's uh economist
i think he could help us talk about the
federalists hilarious right now to have
him on
especially with the bitcoin him and max
guys are together so
i want to i want to point something out
gave a 150 super chat to ask this
question
thank you very much for that super chat
i really do appreciate it yeah but you
have to understand like
someone giving that amount of money to
get a comment read again
asking the same thing we get asked
probably like 50 times every single day
every every day have you heard of every
every time i see the see the comments
i'm just like i don't know when we're
able to book this
guy i just really don't because we had
we had one moment where
um when he showed up in dc when he he
gave nick fuentes gave his speech where
he said sacrifice senate i was like oh
that's
we gotta talk to this guy and then we
have the show and it's just we get
spammed and i'm like i can't i guess we
should have him on
no i can't book him the collective
consciousness is telling us
do it not my collective consciousness
that's why it's happening
because if he came on it would just be
like another anti-climactic awesome show
i think if we book people who who we we
you know we get people flooding the
comments and sending in massive super
chats demanding we do it
i'm not setting that precedent so it's
no disrespect to to nick
i actually have you know some good
friends who want us to have this
conversation
but i'm literally being put in this
mission where he's the only person where
people are dumping money and demanding
it but for all we know the guy that
super chat
never heard you say that before and that
didn't know it was a
big deal he just really cares yeah
that's why i read it and i'm going to
say it again
but but it's it's it's it's a it's a
difficult precedent i've already got
people
finding my phone number and blowing my
phone up for other
people now get a new number yeah joe
gets one like every two weeks
yup that's smart that's right super
smart some some people are calling me
leaving voice mails
and it's like i'm not i'm not playing
this game
i can't do it and so so i guess the
challenge is nothing personal against
nick specifically he's he's much higher
profile
he's been i've even read comments from
it that appeared in news stories
but it's the smaller people that are
spamming me like crazy demanding it i
can't set that price what does nick do i
watched a little bit of this youtube
stuff commentator
america first commentator yeah but
that's that that's
you know i and so i we i read comments
all this all the time and i say the same
thing every time
like you know i had someone i have
someone who keeps calling me i had to
block
probably like 10 numbers already people
demanding to come on the show
oh wow so i don't know right never going
to happen
the one way to make sure we never book
you is to call my phone somehow find the
number i remember a couple months ago i
had someone show up to my house
and literally be like hey can i be on
your youtube channel i'm like how did
you get my
freaking house address like doing here
i'm like
yeah that was pretty uncomfortable so
i'll mention specifically too um
my understanding of nick fuentes is that
he got banned from i
think it was from youtube right i think
so yeah because they were taking clips
out of context
oh he's off youtube right now i guess he
was reading super chats and they they
claimed it was his statement
they got him to say my mike roch
now they they this is a super chat from
money and it was a viral thing to get
him banned
and so there's there's a lot of
interesting things that i think we could
talk about but it's you know i guess
i can't do it if people keep spamming us
you know if people if we get inundated
with non-stop comments it's nice that
you read that guy's super chat
definitely i'll definitely read it
because look it's it's not an issue of
me avoiding comments from people i'm not
going to ignore
people bringing it up but i just want to
let you know like it's bad enough i get
people who are like random people
calling my phone saying like oh i
i you know i have nothing to do with
anything i just you know i live
somewhere and i want to be on the show
and i'm like dude
i get it i respect i appreciate but it's
like
it's there's security issues a bunch of
things so anyway that's the gist of it i
don't want to
harp too long but let's read some more r
uh bracewell says
i got banned on facebook for drug
related for drug related for
screenshotting the ps5q and saying the
page doesn't refresh for two hours
flagged for calling someone lazy for not
looking up info about what's happening
in election
crazy let's see
matt wesley says tim i have never heard
you mention where you are located i
understand not giving out your exact
location for safety
but would you ever be interested in a
meet and greet for local fans uh
we're gonna do semi-private semi-public
kind of events
but it was alex jones who came on the
show and looked me in the eyes and
laughed in my face and said missouri huh
and i was like and then he kept doing it
because he thought it was funny
he was going like i'll do it for the
camera he was like
missouri missouri right and i'm like i
get it alex
you're telling people where i am i
thought he was waiting for me to laugh
and be like oh you got me
rude we're in the woods we're in the
woods in the middle of nowhere
apparently
we're going to do events um and i'll
also let you guys know we're not in
missouri
that was like the joke of documents
we're not in missouri
let's see xd interactive says 85 000 per
person in the us to pay off the us debt
most of that debt is owed to the people
of the u.s though that's true that's
true a lot of people don't realize is
the us debt is like the government
borrowing money to people
that the issue though is the us does
have foreign debt
and also if the u.s can't pay those
people back
then people lose confidence in the
government and then
lots of things happen let's see james
pascarelli says if you do the math
you can paper mache the habitable land
mass of the earth with dollar bills
equal to the us debt
wow great most of it's digital though
most of it's digital yeah it's just
zeros on computers yeah that's so weird
connor murphy says luke have you read
ian smith's memoir bitter harvest
it's about the fall of rhodesia and the
creation of zimbabwe
the timelines are sadly similar i have
not but that sounds like a very
interesting read i did
spend some time in zimbabwe and the
history there is absolutely fascinating
i did look into a little bit about
rhodesia but i'll definitely check out
the book recommendation when i have more
time
what were you doing in zimbabwe uh well
we went in there to talk about the
hyperinflation that happened there
and it was absolutely surreal to talk to
individuals that were sharing their
experiences of them being in grocery
stores and things
literally multiplying in prices right in
front of them
as their currency was hyperinflating and
yeah i got chased away by a couple of
police officers trying to detain me for
filming one of their banks because there
was another bank run there
i interviewed a couple bitcoin
entrepreneurs there that are trying to
bring
cryptocurrencies to africa to bring more
accountability
uh that was an interesting video that i
produced there and
they had a new currency that was backed
by the dollar but it was already
inflating to eight
times when i was there a couple years
ago do you is that stuff on your youtube
channel
uh yeah yep on all on we are change on
youtube
freddie says m1a fires 308 and 762 nato
bought one for the same reason as you
the rounds will punch through
multiple walls easy will penetrate body
armor level 3a
and under not a ton of people uh wear
what stop
762 i guess you get one good shot to the
plate if you're wearing it it's a very
strong bullet but you also have to worry
about the bullet
going through walls and hitting your
neighbors or hitting other people that
you live with
home defense that's why i always
recommended a shotgun i personally have
a shotgun with double barrels that i
could flip on
easily one is lethal one is less lethal
one are rubber bullets
because even if i'm somewhere like in
new hampshire if there's a bear i don't
want to kill a bear no no he's a rubber
bullet dave
dave chappelle broke it down for us you
got to put the birdshot birdshot
buckshot birdshot buckshot
because the first one is a warning the
first one peppers them up a little bit
but then the next one is the seriousness
i have slugs and i have
rubber bullets uh yeah i have a
firearm that i could switch easily and
double yo daddy says is ian stoned
nope he's just like my man
i did smoke weed for about 14 years
though and i think i maybe still is in
my fat cells
probably matthew rakamp says repubs are
control of one state legislator away
from being able to use article 5
convention of states to pass
constitutional amendments without
democrat support
if you could make any proposal at the
convention what would it be
oh man a constitutional convention for
an amendment
with two-thirds of the states really is
that article 5 they need one more
30 states is that all they need what's
the constitutional amendment we need
repeal the federal reserve act
well that's bold um get rid of the uh
slavery if you're in prison thing so the
13th abolishes slavery unless you've
been convicted of a crime so
how about no matter what if you're
convicted of a crime you can't be used
for cheap labor like kamala harris would
like to you know
or just the decentralization of the
federal government so
states have the rights to choose what
they want to do themselves without the
federal government intervening
there's there's there is a there's a
fine line though of course
uh but i think right decentralization is
the way to i got it i got it i got it
what if we what if we added i think i
have a proposal for
probably two two if if we had a
constitutional convention
if the republicans get one more i have
two serious proposals the first
is that the uh the right to freedom of
speech shall not be infringed by the
government
and the second should be that the people
of this country have a right to keep and
bear arms
that needs to be added because
apparently just one of each isn't enough
okay that's a great idea there i like
that idea
it could be our first and second one no
no it would be
uh what what would it be 27 27
amendments is that
how many i'm not sure i'm saying we need
it written twice so you can be like just
so you get it
i wasn't this big on 2a a couple years
ago but i'll tell you when
you watch the insanity in the chaos over
this past year
i'm basically like yeah universal guns
do whatever we lose our free speech
we're led like lambs don't
george washington said well listen
listen dave chappelle is not a
conservative but when he said
the second amendment is just in case the
first one doesn't work out i was like
man that's dave chappelle
historically when you look at gun
control what happens afterwards
total totalitarian government to take
over history doesn't lie
it keeps repentance you know what the
you know what the left is wrong about
every step of the way two big things
they say
what are you gonna do rise up against
the government first of all
no the cons the idea isn't that people
go out and start fighting the government
the idea is the government
doesn't even try the government knows
importantly the the next thing i love so
much is when they say
the founding fathers didn't intend you
intend for you to have a semi-automatic
you know 60 mag rifle or whatever i'm
like bro they had their own warships
with cannons
they had 60 cannons on on a mantle war
and it would go
man blow up whole towns private
individuals owned these things
and they were like yup you don't want
they wouldn't have wanted us to have
like
portable nuclear bombs i don't think
they were differentiating between
weapons at all you could have like
explosions you could have artillery
property like now there's little things
that can blow up entire city blocks like
one guy can walk in with a
with a crazy bomb at the time at the
time
you on your property could have cannons
all over the place that was military
nuclear weapons at the time so nuclear
weapons is another
another realm of explosives maybe there
are certain questions that need to be
asked about the advancement of
technology as it pertains to what the
founding fathers could not have seen
like should everybody have a nuclear
weapon in their house yeah probably a
bad idea
you know yeah because if someone makes
falls down and accidentally sets it off
that could be a nuke could wipe out the
eastern you know some big eastern city
so it's tough let's see daniel maxwell
says glad you guys were able to get some
laughs from that
some humor is needed to reduce the
stress from dealing with msnbs
that's right absolutely from
i don't know that was daniel he made the
joke before yeah
zack summer says tim the atf just raided
the offices of polymer 80.
they took the sales records and then of
yesterday tim of the military arms
channel on youtube said he has sources
they're going door-to-door confiscating
all firearms if they if they find out
you have one
wait if you have what what that's
insanity well the specific uh
regulation that the atf is trying to
pass is they're trying to ban
pistol braces and short barrel kind of
rifles which they personally classified
as pistols
incorrectly obviously so i haven't heard
of that particular story i mean
obviously we're going to look into it
but i don't think it got that severe yet
we just hear some of the protocols but
even with the bump stock law
i mean that was another big egregious
move by the federal government
that turned innocent americans into
felons overnight
and we didn't see government going house
to house with that incident so i don't
see them doing it with this one either
yet
but who never who who who knows in 2020
especially under
a biden presidency derek says judge or
governor for home i don't defense
both of them either basically the same
thing yeah for the most part yes or the
judge is the really long barrel one no
no no they're both they're both
essentially the same but they're the the
revolvers that can take 45
uh long acp and a 410 shotgun yes i
fired one luke's got a video from the
range
where he fires you can hear me laughing
yes there's a big laughter in the
background
that thing's hard to fire but it was fun
i had the
we went to the range and i told the guy
i was like i want to fire a 410 shotgun
i was like you got the governor and he
goes i do but we don't get any bullets
for it and i was like
you have 410 right and he goes you want
to fire the 410 out of the governor and
i was like
why should i not do it all right and i
was like come on
what are you trying to do you're trying
to freak me it wasn't that bad no it's
not that bad yeah
we all we all hit the target dead center
with it yeah you got it
i have the target i'll take a picture of
it i'll put it on instagram
everybody fired and it's like so it's
it's the 410's got four bucks shot the
ones we were i think we were using four
buckshot
uh 410 i think so yeah and so it was
spraying right but ian took a shot that
did a big hole right through the center
of the target my glasses on it was just
like
luke the death star
computer off computer off oh here we go
what is this chad conego says skip the
snw a smith and wesson 500
get a bfr revolver from magnum research
the same people that brought you the
desert eagle pistol
i was half kidding it's just a
ridiculous gun it's massive it's like
the joker you know and he
pulls out the giant revolver that was
hilarious i am not a fan of revolvers to
be honest but yeah
chameleon dx says i own a what does that
say four inch
smith wesson 500 and it's fantastic
you'll love it once we get this big
open uh so you know what's interesting i
actually looked up property in wyoming
the prices are comparable to west
virginia people are telling me wyoming
it's it's it's good big and empty but
the prices are comparable
so it's like if at least in west
virginia you can drive west or east and
find a big city maybe
you don't want that maybe you want to be
in you know wyoming
maybe i don't know the corporation laws
in wyoming are incredible
that's like the the forefront of crypto
yeah
because of that right but you don't need
to live there you they can set you up
with an address
there and then you can run your
corporation from other places dobber
says really have gotten obsessed with
the show lately love the edition of luke
thank you for all you guys do
heart thank you i really appreciate it
thank you so much yes see originally it
was like i think someone cancelled
and we were like yo luke we need you to
come up last minute yeah and you were
like i don't know
man i'm not prepared or whatever no no
no the first time
someone didn't come i'm like fine i'll
do it and then it happened two i think
one more time and then
there was a chance of co-hosting and i
was like no you're like do it
no and then you said no and then you
said no i'm like fine
and then last minute you're like okay
come back in again i'm like fine
whatever i came i came back in and then
there and then another time you said no
because you know what we were doing we
were actually at a point where we're
just going to do guests yeah and if we
didn't have a guess we wouldn't do a
show
yeah exactly but i was like but then
luke was here and i was like just do the
show with luke i guess you know
there's always a lot to talk about i
know dude i feel like we still we only
get in like
one tenth of one percent of what we have
to yeah this is look at this water
dancer says the m1a is effective up to
500 meters of irons according to jet car
but if you're good right you have to be
good at it yeah so that's too
let's make sure that happens so give
that guy a scope yeah you're shooting at
308
so yeah or 762.
all right let's scroll down see what he
got neon
ecstasia says the show became perfect
with luke he's essential
see i'm reading these because now luke
can't leave he's got to stay in the
castle
i've been doing this for way too long
yeah man we need to reveal
well thank you integrity media says
please search 2020 police quitting
this is another point i want to make
sure i bring up when i talk about these
bad cops someone brought up a really
good point the other day i don't think
we
read the super chat but they said it's
no one like don't you realize the reason
the bad cops
are like are in new york they're doing
this it's because the good cops all quit
that's that's a lot of cops walking out
there and so this is quitting the cops
who are staying are the scabs basically
oh that's the ones who are like they're
watching all the bad stuff happening
like i'm not doing this man
and then the scabs are like i don't care
i'll trample over someone's rights if i
get paid
you know oh that's a problem yeah oh we
just gotta jump let's see what is this
bass player 2011 if he says m14 was used
in korea in the start of vietnam
it's still used today as a designated
marksman rifle and a mid-range sniper
rifle in the military
oh that's cool luke told me to order
this like crazy scope system like the
scope is a camera
oh well basically it's it's it's the
best for
the particular situation that we're in
right now especially with the
rangefinder
and especially as a cool toy to play
with and to figure out as well can it
take videos
awesome it could take videos oh that's
awesome dude this is crazy sam finley
says
polymer 80 buy and build kits are under
scrutiny big time they've been going to
homes of customers
that's what the other person said wow
dude well so here so
someone someone comments non-server says
the story about agents raiding homes is
not totally true
they are seizing weapon kits for
unserialized guns that can be put
together
and be fully functional in 20 minutes
whoa that's crazy
that's crazy well in the united states
you can make your own
firearm but you are supposed to put a
serial number on it and then call
the government and know the f notify
them that you do have this so that's
specifically the law
depending on also your state and the
jurisdiction that you're in
that's just on the lower receiver that's
on a function in firearm yeah
the kraken says i hate listening to
people that know nothing about guns try
to explain something about guns
i wish they would ask someone that knows
first that's what i do i mean i straight
up don't know anything about guns i say
it all the time
that's why i was like no guns and i
would have bought a bunch of guns yeah
i'm learning about it and there's
you know no one that it's like or would
you consider yourself an expert
i don't i don't consider myself an
expert in any novice i'm always sure
i'm always learning and i'm always
journeyman
novice amateur is that shooter says
please stop repeating tired fud lines
about
shot like elmer fudd about shotguns
being best home defense please do actual
research on firearms
and all related fields and talk to
actual professionals
in the firearm and self-defense industry
yeah
oh yeah of course yeah always seek
professional assistance don't
base off your decisions off of a podcast
that you randomly heard
as this this from a dude who literally
just bought guns for the first time this
year
and has plastic doll arms yes well the
plastic doll arms are
good for training yeah i don't want to
dog the players michael hunt says luke
is a ds
dlc to tim cast that's the usc what's
the dlc
uh downloadable content yeah it's like
an expansion video game you get a
spanish
daniel smith says tim just break down
and buy a tank you can get one for about
forty thousand dollars
you can't have a functional main gun but
just replace it with a flame thrower
i've seen people do that i have a
flamethrower
but what if you replace the main gun
with like it's not it's more cosmetic
and you actually have just like a
smaller caliber
smaller caliber gun you know what i mean
well you just have that on you anyway
bo darvel says mossberg shockwave
shockwave 12-gauge
yeah very nice well especially if you
have a lot of people around you
and a lot of people living in one space
i think shotguns are definitely the most
appropriate for
home defense depending on the
circumstance depending on the situation
depending on the person who can handle
it there's so many different variables
but
for this one for personally our ones
that i kind of examined here i thought
that was the best why is that
well you want to make sure that you
don't accidentally hurt someone you want
to make sure that
you could also have something that's uh
you know has a big shot that actually
stops whatever threat you have coming at
you
and you could use a different number of
calibers and a different number of
bullets that do a lot of different
things
i can make it i can i can per i
personally know how to make an active
denial system
using a magnetron because i've i've
built some crazy stuff with my friends
back in the day
you want to talk about home defense
imagine having a 2x4 with a magnetron on
it and a can of soup
to direct the beam and a guy breaks in
and he's like what's that ah
and then he goes running screaming
because he feels like he's on fire he
probably could make a home alone
uh version self-defense training videos
it would be interesting
where people take the magnetron from a
microwave they direct it and you can
like point at it
like halogen lights and they light up
yeah it's crazy
it's actually not that complicated to
build i i used to hang out all the
hackers did crazy stuff i made a remote
control can of green tea once
how's that work so it was uh it used uh
we vibrated the can so that the i guess
the way described it is the
the vibrations caused the friction
between the can and the table to become
essentially zero and then the what
generated the friction was
a wheel on the front that spun that was
slightly off center
that created a weight and a vibration so
the can would be weighted forward while
vibrating so you could control it
forward
and then the back of it was a gyroscopic
stabilizer of some plastic 3d printed
heart
that would spin and allow you to if you
if you reduced the spin of the front
weight it would start spinning in
circles
cool and then if you sped it up it would
start going straight again so you could
only go it was a can of green tea that
you could remote control across the
table
would you fill it with water and send it
over to your friend no he just drove it
around because it's hilarious because we
used weird
principles to make something that could
move that shouldn't be able to move and
it was really just me screwing around
like we didn't plan it i was like i'm
going to make a can i was like i duct
taped the motors to it and i was like oh
look what it's doing let's do this and
we just built it it's always moving at a
curve
you're just directing the curve to make
it look straight it'll if if you go
about half power
it the there's a front motor that'll
spin and then it'll the whole camera
starts spinning in circles
and then if you go full power it'll go
straight but then you release it
when it goes straight it's still moving
at a curve that's mitigated it was my
point
it moved the entire universe is a curve
there's no such thing as a straight line
sure
right because you put on the table and
you want to go straight you can make it
go straight you can make it stop and
spin and then change directions two
curves cancelling each other yeah that's
crazy
let's see what do we got there was
wasn't there one big super chat i think
i just had here yes
zack summers says sorry but incorrect
you only have to serialize a firearm if
you plan to sell it
sell or if it's an nfa item i'm not an
expert but i have studied firearm law
for six years what's nfl
national oh the national firearms act is
that what it is yeah yes yes
let's see lee quesenberry says tim i
have the atn scope that's night vision
and records in 4k
federally you don't have to register a
homemade firearm as long as it's
no nfa item interesting i've seen a
bunch of crazy videos of people who have
made their own weapons i don't talk
about
exactly what they are but there's really
simple mechanisms for making homemade
weapons yeah you told me once about a
dude that went into an airport and made
a bomb with all the stuff in the airport
easy that's crazy
and uh i did a video from for uh for
vice we saw the guy went viral
so we met up with him in north carolina
and the dude was a hacker and he was
like
there's things in airports like he made
a grenade
he made a legit fire bomb that burst
into flames and sprayed
i was like wow dude if it's it's so easy
colin there's this guy colin he's like a
youtube engineer he makes like
magnetic shoes where you can walk on the
ceiling and collins know about that
i remember the the video that you're
talking about because this was right
after the tsa started banning water
bottles
and they started throwing everybody's
water away the dude's name is evan booth
he's on twitter you can follow him check
it out
this is a long time ago like eight years
ago and he proved how security is just a
big illusion but he didn't just make
bombs he made a
bunch of he made a crossbow he made he
made a crossbow
he's like i'm gonna make a whole bunch
of weapons that like only using things
you can get in airports
security yeah like you go and you like
you go to the airport
you go through security you go to like a
hudson news and you buy everything you
need
and why i guess i'm i'm i was wrong
about uh you having to register your
firearm
if you only plan on selling it i i don't
know exactly but i'm going to look into
that
i'll let you in the big secret they sell
axe body spray
in airports so this video is all public
so i'll just give you the gist of it
but when lithium comes into contact with
water
it bursts into flames yes you know not
too much water otherwise it'll just
sizzle and dance around the top of it
but if you get if you get lithium which
is in batteries and you can literally
just crack them open and
pull out a sheet of lithium you put a
little water on it and it'll burst
fire will come out so he found a way to
combine these things
with thermoses seal them and then
created a mechanism by which
on contact water breaks like pressurized
lithium in the water and it would cause
explosions and it would cause the
the fuel cartridge was the x body spray
yeah i think i think it's i think is it
body spray is an issue like butane for
or does it not i don't know i have no
idea but it's all
i wouldn't normally explain how he did
it because i think it's a bad idea but
the videos are all publicly on youtube
and there's more than one
and i think one of his videos got taken
down when he explained how to do it
because they were like you're showing
people how to it's too much
yeah too much knowledge but you know
it's really fun he made a club
and the club i think was just rolled up
magazines he took a bunch of rolled up
magazines and then wrapped packing tape
around it and it's like
smashing things with it it's the most
basic weapon but it works
it works yeah anyone can use one in dnd
let's see oh yeah rolly a murray says
home defense get yourself a psd fk
brno 7.5 also look at john lovell and
the warrior poet society network
on how they created their own network
interesting
let's see justin smith says land gold
bitcoin deposit on the new home purchase
best use of best use of nest egg before
the great reset
land it was really funny because i
looked at an rv i just bought an rv
but people got to realize man like
financing is everything
you know most things financed you you
don't want to spend a lot of money to
get your piece of property is that true
because if the economy went nuclear
you know times a thousand would you
still only have to pay off that what you
had finally okay
i mean i don't see why that would be not
the case yeah
so uh like china does currency
manipulation for this reason
they'll be like hey i'll lend you you
know 100 bucks and you're like i know
that with 100 bucks i can buy a phone
right
then they start manipulating their
currency so you can't buy a phone with
100 bucks anymore they double the price
now you know he i owe him less by
manipulating the currency so
i'm just like luke was saying there's
something wrong i have to look into this
because
i mean i would think they would put
something in the contract that it's
adjusted
to inflation or some kind of clause
that's what interest
is what interest is yeah so if you're
locked in an interest rate
then you're good and so i'm like bro if
if you buy something right now
i don't know i could be totally wrong
about this i don't want to be given
advice like i'm not giving anybody
advice but i'm like what would happen if
you had like 50k in debt from buying
something
and then the economy tanked and now
everyone's getting paid a million
dollars an hour at mcdonald's
you pay off the debt like that it'd be
worthless raising the minimum wage
and if if you're in bitcoin and that
goes up times a thousand then you still
only owe the same financed amount i'm
not an expert
lucky cast irl says luke is a must what
a serious asset to have on the squad
always full of great info his channel
needs a boost youtube is after him
that's true
that's absolutely true they've been
after me for a while i was thinking if
this was a movie
like this this life it would be like
when luke's character got there is when
it got really good
i was thinking about that the other you
guys are bringing too nice to him dude
he's like this is like trash
i'm running away he's like the weapons
guy
he's embarrassed oh yeah russell
stallman says yo tim i have a picatinny
scope mount for
a m1a with your name on it hit me up uh
if you go to you if you go to
timcast.com donate there is a p.o box
you can send whatever you'd like to if
you want to send stuff to the show
actually i'll tell you this if you guys
are listening and you want to send luke
some stuff
make it funny make it as funny as you
can i do have a p.o box as well
if people want to send me stuff as well
send them on on wearchange.org forward
slash donate i have my public po box on
there so if you want to send me some
weird stuff
um then they'll show it off we'll shut
off we're going to do a vlog and uh when
we do the vlog we're going to do weird
mail times yeah i mean yeah
i mean i'm not i'm not afraid of the
weird stuff here so uh you know
feel free to send whatever you guys want
i think that guy made a good point that
buying land is the key right now
yeah well i'll tell you this right now
if the apocalypse happens and you own
land
oh right unless you're on it yeah
exactly good point can you defend it no
because you can even be honest with it
and let's say you own 100 acres right
and you're like this is my land the
apocalypse happens some hippies are
going to shout and be like bro you can't
like own land man and you're gonna be
like
the hell i can't he's gonna and he's
gonna go shh yeah you wanna talk about
it
and if you're working on a nice scope
for the m1 just to you know
i don't think if you hire guards they
could just be like it's our land now
we're going to get this land we're going
to build dirt jumps
we're going to make a shooting range and
stuff and have this like space where we
can do fun videos
on collider hacking lasers just like you
know
so we can do airsoft games razer tag
yeah and build big dumb housing like
isn't kanye kanye west is going to help
us build domes he's going to help us
sure sure but isn't he doing that yeah
he's building
domes for the homeless right now easy
yeah he is on the pulse
bruce a the second says tim poole guys
we're wandering into dangerous territory
also tim pool hey guys want to make
bombs out of household items it's easy
no
no no disclaimer i'm saying
that was a video i did like seven years
ago for vice
but when we go out into the middle of
nowhere we're gonna be doing a bunch of
like special effects hacking i'm not
you know i got to be honest i think
bombs are like low brow
people like making videos and they're
like you know so they had mythbusters
right and the mythbusters episodes that
did really well with the ones with
explosions
so they made some like show that was
just people making explosions and i'm
like
nah you gotta do something fun like
lasers here's what i want to do
can we make some kind of like flying
device that can
be powered by pointing a laser at it
things like that yeah probably like a
super lightweight aluminum
craft with some kind of you know uh
energy conversion of sort
ionic lift or something photovoltaic or
whatever i should get jeremy risk the
alien scientist
do they're about to do like a million
watt
gig with some massive energy power
source that they're you know what i want
to do
remember in super mario bros the movie
they had those things they put on their
legs
that were like hydraulic and they could
jump super high and then when they
landed it compressed again
would that blow your legs apart maybe
yeah okay
i was reading something about a a metal
frame suit
that you can get that uh allows you to
lift things
there's like a video i watched where
darpa has that that developing the
supersoul
but i'm not talking about skeletons but
not powered like totally
mechanical pulleys like it's springs in
a metal frame
and you have hooks and you hook it to
something and then it makes it it's like
hydraulics because you can lift it
really easily there's a bunch of cool
stuff we can do like that oh yeah
that being said everybody let's do one
more we got here the the best one willie
billy the hillbilly says you should have
colleen noir on the show
a firearm and firearm law expert or
james from tfb tv another gun expert
yes i'd love to have colleen noir he's
awesome standing invite
yeah standing invite and i think it's
just an issue of travel and kovit for
most people so we'll see
uh i mean you know but uh i look forward
to having
uh oh what is this t-pain says tim i own
an ammo company impact ammo i cannot
send ammo to a po box
um send me an email if you go to
timcast.com there's a contact section
send an email
and uh we'll uh you know just send me
the information we'll figure it out
regarding jeremy's power source it's a 1
million volt marks
generator and he's ready to make some
plasma i got an idea for a show i wanted
to do
where we do a live stream and then we
take some kind of like
electrodes or whatever and hook it to
random objects and then
the voltage or whatever whatever the
right word is i don't know because i'm
an electrician
uh or an engineer the the the power
going into the thing we hook up to it
will be based on how many live viewers
we have
so what happens is you'll have like 10
000 people watching
and it'll be like 10 000 volts and
nothing will be happening you could use
smart contracts for that like
cryptocurrency
no you just need to no you just tell
people to come and watch the show
by being there it could mine a crypto
that causes the generator to click
away that's how you could automate the
system we wouldn't need to do that we
would just have it so we turn it up as
they showed up yes
no you oh it's it's probably like one
line of code to be like
voltage equal view count that's just
that simple yeah i just want to make
crypto
yeah we could make the crypto people can
have it it would be i don't know
whatever
tokens yeah you know it was erc20 tokens
but that's the idea so then people are
like share with your friends
because if you don't then you're not
going to get that that's a great idea
yeah it'd be fun we're going to get a
big open crazy land and do it and
i got the idea because watching that
hydraulic press channel where they were
crushing things
and i was like what would happen if you
like took a teddy bear got it soaking
wet and then hooked it up
what would happen nothing what if the
teddy bear didn't have
any water on it would it just nothing
because there's no contact you have to
test
yeah yeah and we got to get a super
slo-mo camera
because i want to watch the electricity
yes well that's ridiculous those rigs
are massive to see electricity arc
let's fund it let's get a funded
electricity you're talking about a
gigantic
we could maybe get one of those like you
know a couple thousand frame second
cameras
yeah i want the state of the art where
you can see bullets come out in slow
motion yeah that's
way too expensive you gotta be in like
super bright rooms crazy it's all for
the art
right on ladies and gentlemen if you
have not already smash that like button
because it really really does help and
share the show with your friends if you
think it's
we're doing a good job because uh that's
how we grow the channel we grow the show
leave a good review if you're on itunes
or spotify or any other podcast platform
because again that really helps boost us
in the rankings and uh sharing is the
best thing you can do
don't forget to like subscribe hit the
notification bell we're live monday
friday at 8pm
luke oh here i hear you're a person with
social medias yes yes yes you can follow
me on luke we are change on twitter and
instagram and coincidentally i'm also
wearing another we are changed t-shirt
this one saying gives me that by a
homeless person
extra points if you could guess who this
is and check out more information on my
youtube channel uh we are change thanks
again
so much for having me but there are
people who are only listening so it's
karl marx yes
uh ian hi everyone i'm ian crossland you
can follow me
uh on many in most social networks city
and crossland including my instagram
where
you can see luke shoveling the snow off
the roof of his rv
and uh twitter where i usually interact
with people the most
also minds i co-founded mines with bill
ottman in 2010
and i think it's a great potential to
use as a fresh
new source code for a new social network
yeah if we're going to expand to use
free software so follow me on mines
right on and of course you can follow at
star patch lids who's pushing all the
buttons i'm on twitter i talk to people
on twitter it's very fun join me there
ladies and gentlemen we'll be back
tomorrow 8 p.m
uh we're gonna have a really really
interesting big show yeah i'm excited
i want to confront him on something it's
going to be very big it's going to be a
little controversial but very funny
cause trouble yes there's going to be
trouble tomorrow
right on thanks for hanging out
everybody we will see you tomorrow and
we were talking about foreign
interference the election
crazy conspiracies all that good stuff
thanks for hanging out everybody we'll
see you tomorrow
bye guys
you